black lives matter
insurrectionist have stormed the capital
outraged over a law that they disagree
with
ladies and gentlemen we can't stand for
this we need the fbi to put up
billboards across this country seeking
these
insurrectionists we need months of
coverage from every mainstream media
outlet
we cannot allow insurrectionists to
storm our capital buildings
in oklahoma city okay it happened in
oklahoma city it was at the capitol in
washington d.c but you get my point and
why i titled it this way
we have three plus months because they
stormed the capital and they shouldn't
have and it was bad and it was
substantially worse than what we saw in
oklahoma city
but there have been many circumstances
when leftist activists
have broken into government buildings
shut them down and now we have it
happening and there's nothing
i don't expect them to come out and
scream the world is ending like they did
for trump but at least be like yo
y'all shouldn't be doing this while
we're complaining about other people
doing something similar
but of course the media is a double
standard so we have much to talk about
in this space we also have joy behar
arguing that cops should fire their guns
wildly into the air
to scare 16 year olds who are in knife
fights which is the stupidest advice
i've ever heard i'm so proud
and we have a really big breaking story
ladies and gentlemen ben
shapiro bought wood from home depot and
it's lighting internet up
we must have a very fierce debate over
whether or not it was appropriate for
ben shapiro to film a video going to
home depot and buying
he or did he buy like a two by six i
have no idea one by six
it's probably really expensive it was a
plank of work chrysler lumber's going up
he was just flexing on us he's like okay
look how much money i have ladies
that's what like dude rappers are going
to start doing in music videos they're
just going to buy a bunch of lumber
all right uh you can probably guess
seamus is here i'm here ladies and
gentlemen boys and girls
i am low energy sheamus today i barely
got any sleep this week but myself
and my team we cranked out three
cartoons we released three cartoons
three days in a row check us out
youtube.com freedom tunes we are three
thousand subs away from reaching six
hundred thousand
so please go over there smash that
subscribe button
three videos i couldn't imagine how hard
it must be to do three videos in a week
you know what tim
dude i am gonna hit you so hard bro i'm
winding up i might be low energy but i'm
not that low energy
dude my my team is fantastic yeah no we
were
just dashing around over there just some
illinois boys jashing around
uh but yeah thank you so much for having
me we got we got you what's up everybody
ian crossland up in this corner oh yeah
yeah but we
throw it down we put the picture of joe
biden and eating the child behind
uh ian there it is yeah we're trying to
balance out the areas like i've been
waiting for that
i felt so alone because we had to move
it over because you know
he's like it was like the wall was kind
of blank yesterday framing
yeah and there's me in the corner i
don't have any art behind me and i feel
really left out but neither does tim so
it's okay
ladies and gentlemen before we get
started we have an amazing sponsor today
in the link below you will see
the the website surfing internet safe go
there
and you can get a virtual private
network service from virtual shield
50 off for life what is a vpn you may
you might ask it is a basic level of
protection and security for you while
you browse the internet
i always say we don't expect people to
break into our homes we still lock our
doors in windows
if you're concerned about hackers
government spying or just like corporate
spying which is
really commonplace you know we talked
about it quite a bit yesterday they're
spying on you
to an absurd degree get a vpn because it
does help protect you now no protection
is perfect but this is a basic level of
security
it's called the virtual private network
go to surfinginternetsafe.com and for
2.50 cents per month you can get
the virtual shield vpn and they say you
get 24 months with their with their
trouts
actually for only 59.88 that's actually
77 off if you use that deal
plus you get 50 percent of all add-ons
and other great discounts on other plans
they're proud to announce that this
month all discounts are guaranteed for
life
that means 50 off for as long as you are
a customer
my friends another thing i always
mention whenever you hear me shout out
virtual shield they are my first sponsor
from when i had a wee tiny little
youtube channel with like no subscribers
they were like yo we like this guy
we want him to shout us out and i was
like yes you guys rock thank you for
supporting my channel
for the past several years and helping
us grow to as big as we are i love you
guys virtual shield seriously i mean it
you you've been there every step of the
way through all the adpocalypse and
everything they're like nah you're good
man we dig what you do and we
we you know we dig the shout out so i'm
eternally grateful go to surfing
internetsafe.com
get the vpn and again many thank you uh
many thanks and also go to timcast.com
become a member
and right up top you will see a little
button says members area you can click
that
and you will see all of these really
amazing members only segments in the top
right you see members only you click
that you can sign up you can click any
one of these
log in become a member sign up and then
you can watch this great stuff we had a
i gotta say man
the member's only thing we did with
charlie the duff last night it was a
dramatic change in tone
from the whole show he did everybody was
saying like they loved charlie he was
hilarious he was rambunctious they
didn't agree with him a lot of things
you know he had an emotional argument
about chovin but when we go into this
members only segment he got real serious
he told us a really
dark story you know he was a journalist
covering 911
a reporter and he saw some really messed
up stuff from crooked journalists these
crooked reporters
scumbags man i i was you guys got to
check it out seriously
timcast.com members only sign up
it's serious man it was it was it was a
great segment so charlie you rock thanks
for coming and uh let's jump into this
first story my friends
from fox news black you know it's funny
okay
even fox news won't go as far as the
rest of the mainstream media when
they're talking about these stories they
say
black lives matter protesters storm
oklahoma capital over gop bills
protecting drivers fleeing riots
police from doxing more than two dozen
protesters filled gallery
while oklahoma house was in session
that's the news
fox news will not say insurrectionists
storming you know insurrectionists they
won't say it
the mainstream press will set about
trump supporters all day and night all
day
there's no real meaningful opposition i
got to be honest
you look at fox news right sean hannity
was like the derek show of inverted was
the correct verdict
tucker carlson was like no it wasn't
even fox news can't agree
on whether or not they support the cop
or they support
the guilty verdict even when you look to
fox news and other conservative outlets
they're not going to say
insurrectionists storm the capital they
won't do it
so that's that's a huge issue i suppose
these
these extremists are protected even by
conservative media
why i guess because conservative doesn't
want to play that game for the most part
yeah i think i'd probably be more in
line with with hannity on the chauvin
question but when it comes to the
capital being stormed
even though again this is not the
capital this is in oklahoma
nothing that happens in oklahoma matters
as they say
so it doesn't matter uh yeah it's crazy
to me i think part of it might be that
fox wants to try to appear more neutral
because they have the
like the baggage being considered a
biased network and other networks just
don't people know cnn is biased but for
whatever reason they've they've
been able to play themselves off as
neutral for many years
i don't think foxes had that luxury i
really do think it's an overreaction to
the perception that they're biased
maybe yeah i don't know it's really
weird tucker carlson's opinions are very
very different from
the traditional opinions of the network
you know what i mean yeah no and that's
part of why i enjoy watching him so much
yeah no i think the issue is there's
the on the right and the disaffected
liberals anti-woke anti-establishment
there's the rules and the exceptions and
they differ from the rules and
exceptions of the democrat side
on the democrat side you have
establishment media the act of
stenographers for the state
and they will say the most insane and
most extreme things like i don't know
maybe they'll say something like
tucker carlson had a psychotic break on
his show last night because he was
laughing like you know like a crazy
person
sure i guess tucker laughed you know
outrageously
it wouldn't call it a psychotic break
but you'll get that from you know
mainstream press you'll get that from
partisan left press
if that's a psychotic break what do you
call what kamal has been doing
she's like breaking down into psychotic
laughter constantly it's like her whole
thing
well most of what she does there's a
difference between megalomania and
psychosis okay that's a really good
point it's a fine line
but i suppose there is a difference can
we you know you know is missing from
kamala though
a mustache that she can twirl squirrel
oh my goodness you gotta twirl the
mustache
i i i would be more believing of it i'd
be like yeah i can see it
no i mean it's interesting so this was
what this was an anti-rioting bill
oh yeah oklahoma cities passed the
anti-writing bill they made it law
and this one's interesting i think this
one's actually a bit better than
florida's because this one makes it a
misdemeanor to obstruct a roadway
instead of a felony
i don't think it should be a felony for
a bunch of protesters block a street it
should certainly be illegal
they make it a serious felony get up to
a year in jail for blocking a street
i think that's appropriate i think
non-violence of disobedience should be
you know like respected to a certain
degree you do it you still get arrested
though you commit a crime blocking the
street you get arrested i don't know i
mean
i'm just thinking out loud here i don't
really have a strong opinion on whether
that should be a misdemeanor or a felony
but if you block the street you can
prevent an ambulance from getting
through and people can die as a result
well that's a different charge though
isn't it okay so if there was a but then
here's the question
if i'm blocking a roadway and there's
some amount of traffic and many cars
back there's an ambulance which i can't
see
and now somebody dies but i was unaware
what kind of charge is that do i still
get hit
yeah that's murder yeah okay so we're
fine with that the issue is
a felony charge for you know marching on
the street and saying dumb stuff i don't
think so man that means you can't vote
you can't get a gun you can't travel
yeah you know we had we had this debate
already the other day i think with will
chamberlain he was very much in favor of
the of the felony
but in oklahoma city they passed his
anti-riot bill
and it specifically says that if you're
fleeing a riot
you're not civilly liable if you know
you hit somebody
and they're they're protesting this
storming the capital demanding the right
to like mercilessly beat drugs that's
insane that's insane
right and i think i think that's
probably the the happy middle ground if
you could call it that
to just say yeah no if you're behind the
wheel of a car and people are riding and
you feel threatened it's fine to just
drive through them it's an ugly
situation you hope you're never in it
but people have to be able to protect
themselves
i don't know it sounds like something
that should storm the capital yeah i
think they should storm the capital
well here's the thing tim this is an
anti-rioting bill and you could say it's
ironic that they ride it over an
anti-writing bill but they really didn't
write they committed insurrection so
there was a couple moves ahead of us
i'm confused as what the rules are right
now like there are none
am i allowed to support black lives
matter insurrection or is that still
promoting insurrection you know what i
mean like of course not tim you of
course
there are no rules there are no
standards for them of course you can
support that kind of hold on
it's a mostly peaceful insurrection yes
yes
so as long as you say peaceful protest
you can say whatever you want right
basically yeah whatever you want
the the the incoming peaceful protests
that we will see over the summer from
black lives matter
will leave a wake of destruction fire
and death
it's like well dude they said it was
peaceful all right it's right on the
flyer mostly
yes we did do a cartoon it's called
mostly peaceful maxine waters if you
guys want to check that out that was
the third of a series of as i mentioned
three cartoons we did in one week
we're pretty proud of it check it out
wow
she's a hoot you know you know one of
the challenges with this because we were
talking about before
we went live i was like this is just so
redundant i know it's like this time
like oh look they did it again and the
media doesn't care i know well this is
hilarious because
every once there's a video i did a
couple years ago
on gun violence this must have been 2015
2016 maybe 2017
i bet i still got it wrong even though i
threw three different years out but
in the video i say that one of the
reasons we need the second amendment one
reason people should be able to own
assault rifles is because inner city
shop owners and other people living in
these neighborhoods might need to be
able to protect themselves from multiple
people when there are riots because the
media irresponsibly riles up racial
tensions
and so people are commenting on this
over the past couple months oh you're a
prophet you saw this coming
it's like no it's just that the news
media is all reruns this stuff keeps
happening over and over and over again i
didn't predict anything i just made a
cartoon about what was happening
and it's relevant again you know would
have been funny if bernie sanders won
and they were like the bernie bros
they're staging an insurrection at the
capitol
because they were doing that like you
you were mentioning that earlier weren't
you
somebody earlier was like bernie almost
got the same oh we were talking about
that
i wasn't the one who brought it up but
no it's true bernie almost got the exact
same treatment that
that trump got yes were they they're
calling bernie bros they're saying
they're really violent they were
or at least that their rhetoric was
violent they were being misogynistic and
harassing women on the other
it's almost like all this social justice
stuff is just an excuse to silent
dissent they don't actually care
it's just about getting their political
goals across yeah that sounds about
right
man but i'm just you know i kind of wish
we were in that timeline
where it's like bernie sanders he's like
go home go be peaceful you're my special
voice
go home my special voice everything it's
true go home it's okay could you imagine
a special voice
i mean the funny thing is we are seeing
the bernie bros committing acts of
violence
burning things down they're
substantially more violent than trump
supporters are
yeah i guess we don't know exactly how
many of them are bernie bros but we know
there's some come on dude yeah i know i
know there are
a lot yeah yeah and they're going around
burning stuff down and the media is just
like let's not
you know bernie you know he said vote
for hillary
exactly now if he hadn't said vote for
hillary they would have been like
this this seditionist movement
within the democratic party well it's
crazy though because
i mean you look at this you look at
these riots that are occurring and it
just becomes obvious that this is like
the militant arm of the democratic party
i'm not the first to say this but
there's sort of a like a wink and a nod
you know they're cutting them loose
they're dropping the charges yeah i
would i would just
you know i don't want something like
that to happen i would just i have to
admit i'd be thoroughly entertained by
bernie sanders being like
the one percent need to face justice
take to the streets and then like auntie
was running around and they were like
waving bernie flags that have trump
flags and they're like
you know he's like here's how we're
going to destroy the one percent
find a small business and throw a brick
through the window
that will show them i don't know what
antifa is thinking but it seems to be
their status that's their plan it's a
brilliant strategy
it's unfortunate we we live in a it's
it's a like you said it's a rerun man
it's like 2021 it was going to see the
same thing over and over again
no because it's just going to get worse
and worse and worse until it collapses
right if if we don't change course this
can't just keep happening
it'd be cool if it was kind of like game
of thrones though where we have this
really intense
first few seasons and then the last
season is just like a crudely drawn
horse and we're all confused to what's
no i think we're getting i gotta be
honest i do think it's like that right
so
2021 was like the first six seasons i
guess of game of thrones where
everyone's all like
it's intense and everyone's like donald
trump it's the most important bang in
the table
and now we have this year where the
democrats are like child knife fights
are normal and
yeah no that was horrible uh the two
girls no need to the democrats saying
arguing that no teenage knife fights are
normal in the politicians
you ever go to boy scout camp you know
you get your whittling chip and then all
of a sudden people just start like
stabbing each other
dude when when when i was a kid in
in southern chicago every child was
running around with some kind of knife
exactly everybody no they wanted to make
sure everyone had a knife
that's fair how insane is this that they
they literally were defending that
that's that that's what i'm saying they
jumped the shark right fonzie was you
know you know jumped the shark john
fonzie
yeah yeah jet ski right is that what it
was no
i think he jumped a shark on water skis
or something he was over a ramp that was
a motorcycle it could have been
that's where we're at i was sitting
there and you know i was i was working
on my my show for 4 p.m
and i'm like i have this thing about you
know new new police training measures
and police accountability oh my god this
is going to be this is crazy the police
departments are responding
and then i see these these tweets where
it's like children have knife fights all
the time and i was like that's normal
bro
no didn't you tim didn't you have a
brother i mean come on this is normal
stuff
me and my siblings got a knife i'm just
like no i want to know how i got these
scars
i'm just telling people like please if
there's any segment of mine you've ever
shared
share the one where i'm showing the
tweets from democratic personalities
saying that teenagers should be allowed
to have knife fights sim
normalized kids having no no no no no
they said that not me i know i'm saying
no i know i know i'm just i'm making fun
of them
you have to have the clap emojis in
there normalize kids
having a knife and then it was uh it was
bree newsome
who like locked her accounts because
everybody was like yo are you are you
serious with this but like also how do
we look is it valerie jarrett
yes valley jerry she's like let the
children have their knife fights
how do we live in a world where using
the wrong pronouns is violent
but like it's normal for kids it's so
weird they're hyper
sensitive about really weird things like
if you use the wrong pronouns you're
like if you don't support the welfare
state you want everyone to die but then
they're like super in favor of abortion
apparently now child knife fights are
like a normal thing
it's weird how they just they shut their
empathy bro get out of cities
okay cops are resigning all right cops
are resigning in large numbers
actually let me pull this one up we have
this side this is just another story
there's a bunch of these stories we have
this from kob.com
more than a dozen apd officers resigned
from emergency response team
following weekend protest there's a
total of 20 officers who resign
we're now seeing across the country
recruitment levels are at historical
lows
baltimore is facing between a 500 and
700 officer shortage
crime is skyrocketing nobody nobody
wants to be involved in this stuff
anymore
so i'm telling people listen i've been
saying for how long get out of the
cities
jack bosobic has been saying it yeah a
lot of people a lot of people are saying
it's not that easy i'm like i hear you
dude i get it i get it but listen
they're taking your cops away the cops
are quitting and now they're telling
your kids to have knife fights
yeah at a certain point you're gonna be
like i don't
i ca these people are are lunatics they
clearly don't have any principles
the mo like come on but they're living
in cities is really cool tim you like
take the subway and meet interesting
people and you can
go to the
charlie the dust on the show yesterday
yeah and i'm like look at this about the
police stuff he's like come on no one's
really talking about like no and i'm
like
look and and i think you agree with me
on this one i was like i i understand
most people don't want this
but most people aren't actually sticking
up for the police so what happens is the
activists go out they write they bring
stuff down
the writers go crazy then the city says
okay we're going to abolish or defund
the police
then they do then the cops quit then the
crime skyrockets because the regular
people aren't getting involved i'll tell
you this
the moment they start saying teenagers
should be able to have knife fights
you think we're all laughing how stupid
it is right but look what they say with
the polish the police i know we started
losing police officers
i'm not saying we're going to see more
teenage knife fights i don't know for
sure
yeah i'm just saying there is a
possibility that if they start
encouraging this
cops are going to be like i'm not
getting involved yeah i don't know yeah
i have no idea if they're really
encouraging it
it's just to me it seems like a really
like stupid attempt on their part to own
the cons like
knife fights are normal dude no joke
they're they're they're arguing
that's what they're arguing okay so but
but more to the point i suppose because
we i don't want to be the dead horse
i want to stab it because that's normal
that no
normal cops are leaving yeah and i've
been saying what over the past several
weeks
several months cops should resign i said
this months ago
so i i want to i want to say to the cops
recording i'm my applause i'm applausing
and i i totally get it but then on the
other hand it's like this is kind of
exactly what they want this is exactly
what blm wants
and i think they should get what they
want really i don't live there do you
normal knife fights but here's the thing
but people
here's the thing people are going to
move from those cities
into our like more rural areas and
they're going to vote for the same
really stupid policies that destroyed
their cities
and then all of america is gone that i
think should be actively
resisted and challenged you got to be
active in your community
you got to make sure those things don't
happen and you got to make sure you
stand up for your community
if so so i i i was being told this story
by a guy at a gun shop he said
that they had a gun range and they shoot
guns all the time and they started
building developments around it now all
of a sudden the people who live there
are complaining about the gun range and
it's like bro the gun range was there
before you got there yeah
that means if you live in this community
and people start moving
how strong is your community how strong
are your rules laws policies
yeah and will you tell these people we
are going to keep our guns we're going
to to do what we've been doing you can't
change that
if you want to come here accept the way
we live but
doesn't this doesn't everything that's
happened over the past couple months
sort of proved that conservatives are
more or less just rolling over and
taking it
and so that's exactly what's going to
happen when left-wing people start to
move to more conservative cities they're
going to like
oh well i guess you can have the bump
stock or we already we already
sacrificed that but i guess
you can have this or that or the other
will allow you to take away semi-autos
or
i think semi-autis is where a lot of
people would draw the line and might
actually fight but they're going to keep
stripping away at gun rights they'll
probably add some insane taxes to
ammunition they've been trying that for
years right regular people don't know
anything i think regular people well i
think that's the point though i think
regular people just don't care
right for the most part and so they
allow these things to happen and then i
think conservatives just stay quiet
about it
yeah the left-wing people are never
afraid to tell you that they're
left-wing
but conservatives often are and i've
said this before it's because
the conservative movement has has lost
all of its supernatural faith and so
everything becomes about worldly power
in a strange way they start to worship
human respect and they want to be seen
as cool and normal and they want to fit
in
they're less concerned with the truth
and they're more concerned with their
own personal reputations
so they don't stand up when they need to
stand up and that's why our country's
gone
they're let well there's no meaningful
opposition to
the left it's not necessarily about just
conservatives yeah about
moderates as well what's about the truth
right so what happens is
you know it was described to me years
ago that conservatives are basically
holding the left and the left is slowly
dragging them yes but that restraint
from conservatives means we slowly move
left in a lot of policy issues
whether or not whether conservatives
want it or not they're still actively
resisting
now what's happened is the rope has
broken republicans and conservatives
have fallen down and the left has just
gone so far left they jumped off the
cliff 100
and this is what i think now there are
some left-wing policies or positions
that i will encounter rarely which i'll
say yeah like
that makes sense where i understand
where you're coming from at the very
least
but leftism taken as a whole is more or
less a sign of social decay
and everything humans create fall apart
eventually or falls apart eventually
and so i think they just have an edge
there it's really difficult to build and
it's really easy to destroy and so much
of what the left does is destroy what
was already there
i disagree i think you need to
differentiate between
the weird cult stuff they do that makes
no sense that we're tribalism
and like left economics versus right
economics you know what i mean
sure yeah i mean like if we're gonna
have a discussion on like supply side
versus demand side or something like
that but when you talk about
like so i'm talking about like i'm
talking about leftism like
authoritarianism
just leftism in general authoritarian
leftists as well but i'm talking about
in this country yeah i'm talking about
basically
marxism critical theory the antifa type
exactly yeah yeah exactly i agree with
you that there are some left
and that's why i said earlier there are
like certain left-wing positions or
ideas that i can kind of understand
where they're coming from or even agree
with on some occasions but
leftism as we're discussing it i mean
i think there's like we're like antifa
blm right i think leftist policy
regardless is extremely hard because it
requires centralization
anti-authoritarian decentralization is
nearly impossible so that's like
libertarian left
it's like those are that's a unicorn you
know what i mean like finding someone
who can actually
run really becoming is just never going
to happen
but but free trade and free markets a
lot easier
so i like the idea of you know living on
a hippie farm and sharing your your
your bounty with your friends and
everything but doesn't scale up into a
society well and then here's the weird
thing about like
a free market and free trade when you
have a free market in free trade gdp
grows
and then the government sees that and
they start to want more of a slice of
that and you get politicians who promise
the public that they'll give them
other people's money if they vote for
them so as your economy improves due to
a free market you actually
end up with this growth of state power
it's a very strange
i think i think the paradox i think the
centralization of power regardless is
the problem you know what i mean
like one corporation that owns
everything or a government that has
authoritarian control over everything
yeah it's difficult to uh
actuate i keep thinking of the art of
war and like uh if there are two sides
in a battle you've got the authoritarian
left this this like
leftist communist thing like organizing
and then
attacking this like well-entrenched army
of like
you know righteousness whatever 2a
supporters and they want to
now they're in a skirmish and it's all
this stuff like fire into the air
they've got the the plebes like
talking about it and that's the skirmish
and they want to
draw them in out into the open and catch
them with a mistake so that they can
create law
that will make things illegal and like
like banning guns and things so so it's
like they're goading
the the the 2a whatever you want to call
them like the i the i
create the reason yeah for the
authoritarianism right um
so i can't i'm going to try to work
through this on my like four hours of
sleep this week
but i would argue that not all authority
is equal
but that said i would agree that
generally speaking at some point
a central authority just becomes too
large or it's attempting to manage too
much
i think it could very well be the case
that even governments
which attempt to oversee a geography the
size of one of our smaller states are
too large
because our populations are are too
diverse we don't really share
values anymore i don't know how you have
one set of laws governing a country
of 330 million people well so going back
to the point about
police resigning and you know people
moving out of cities the issue is
it doesn't make sense for joe biden to
ban guns in west virginia
like okay i get it you're an urban
liberal exactly exactly cubicle
apartment
but i'm in the mountain you know i mean
we've got coyotes and bears and stuff we
we need to be
able to protect ourselves and our
friends our family our animals and
things like that
they don't understand and they don't
care so a blanket law
that's the craziest thing because bernie
brought that up man he said the gun
debate was an urban versus rural issue
100
100 so much of gun violence is gang
violence in the inner city
or just like honor violence like a lot
of people are like ego and pride and
they're like don't you tell me yeah you
know
yeah their gun and stuff so the way i
see it man
if new york wants to have their own way
of passing laws and doing things
i'm i'm down for that just i won't live
there you know i lived in new york i
left i didn't like it
moved to new jersey and said eh i'm
growing i don't like this either and i
moved down to the philly area still in
the jersey side yeah don't like this
now i'm in the middle of nowhere i like
it a lot better granted that
when i live in these places i did like
it but eventually decided i wanted
something
different and i said yeah i changed it
and so i got no beef
look did you see this video that went
viral where a woman in new york runs up
to another one and puts a ball in her
head
no what no yeah i didn't see that one
that is it was uh apparently
two women who were who were lovers they
broke up or something 38 year old woman
runs up and it's on video and they got
the video
and she just right to the head yeah oh
now here's the thing it's horrible
it's not you guys didn't hear about it
no national story
no black lives matter protest yeah no
they want this
listen i'm not trying to be a dick i'm
i'm actually getting
angry at conservatives where they're
like why aren't the police there and i'm
like bro they've asked you to take the
police away
stop telling other people how to live
their lives that's not you living there
that's not you dealing with a street
crime they don't complain about it
they're not marching for it because they
don't care
now i'll tell you what they do care
about when the cop shows up
and tells the girl to drop the knife
they yelled at the cop who did that
that's insane listen
the cop shouldn't go there and it's not
an issue of
fine if they don't want our help we
won't give it no dude if if
if i'm like if if somebody is going to a
neighborhood
and the people are like yo we would
appreciate if you did not come into our
neighborhood
why would you be like no i should go
into your neighborhood
did you see the the video of that young
man
chanting like we don't want white people
here in new york
yeah yeah yeah that's a white guy
yelling at white people yes
dude perfectly summarizes the left right
now
so the issue i suppose is people are
worried about these people moving into
the country
or at least like regular uninitiated
like
people moving into this country and then
voting for these things you need to
be active in your community you need to
be active in your schools
you need to be active in local politics
and local law and local media
otherwise if you sit back and think
we're you know we're safe here at the
mountain no it'll come dude it's gonna
if they're gonna come to your
neighborhoods if you're not paying
attention reach
you need to have responsibility for the
things in your community
you need to have responsibility for your
community watch for where you live maybe
it's easier to be in the middle of
nowhere you don't interact with a whole
lot of people
but once they start moving out of these
cities and they will then you just need
to make sure you are
being active and making sure they don't
pass along because i'll tell you this
what's already happening in west
virginia
people from the dc area come into the
west virginia area and then they run for
the school account you know school board
or whatever and then they're all
marxists they're all critical race
theorists teach your kid about
transgenderism and the people who live
there don't pay attention
yep they're not active in the schools
all of a sudden now their kids are
coming back and they're like i'm a
communist and they're like
why well did you go to your school did
you talk to your teachers did you ask
them what they're teaching your kids did
you pay attention you didn't they're
trying to do this
you need to be active you can't just
ignore it that being said
i think it's the most important point
that we have
a stat a 13 year old 13 year old girl
stabbed and killed another
was another 13 year old girl yeah
there's no black lives matter marches
there's no lebron james it's because
they're begging you
please let us do this who am i to impose
my will on a different community that is
saying they want to have retribution
killings or whatever
i'ma tell you this i don't like it i
think we have police for a reason but i
don't live there
i'm not going to tell people who live in
a certain place because i'll tell you
this you know what i would prefer
i would prefer the right to bear arms
where i live and that means there may
come a time
where there's a video of me and
someone's breaking to my home and i
defend myself
and then all these people share the
video and they're like why weren't the
police there you should no no
no no my house my community i think we
have the rules the way we voted for them
we should deal with it new york can do
what they want
stop acting this is what i don't
understand conservatives don't live in
these places
and i guess the only argument for the
most part is probably other arguments
for sure
is that we don't want them coming to our
neighborhoods then be active in your
neighborhood yeah i think that
if there's anything you just said there
that i definitely really agree with and
with seize on it's
to tell people at home to really get
involved with local politics don't be
the stereotypical conservative who just
rolls over and lets the left have their
way
really have your voice heard locally
these large
federal elections you know when we're
voting for the new president or even if
you're voting for a representative in
the house of representatives or for a
congress person
i'm not saying those aren't important
but what's really important is local
politics
and yeah there probably is going to be a
mass exodus from these big cities so if
you're in a state like uh
illinois well first of all you shouldn't
be you should probably leave
unless you vote for the left then stay
there you made your bed lay in it
if you're gonna move somewhere else
please vote for different kinds of laws
don't try the same thing twice
i'm sure you will but if if you are a
sane person living in a sane part of the
country
now is the time where you have to get
really really involved to ensure that
the left-wing people who are coming into
your communities don't influence
legislation
such that your county turns into new
york let me just write this down another
way right
if you were in west virginia almost uh i
think iowa
was at utah constitutional carry if
you're in west virginia and you've got
uh uh
ar15 556 and you got it decked out it's
a beautiful
you know beautiful weapon and you're
walking down the street west virginia
you know the cops going to say to you
good morning nice good morning let me
check it out dude absolutely he might
ask me something if he's friendlier he
might ask you some questions about it
look oh that thing's sick or did you get
it yeah
absolutely he might be like nice nice
where'd you pick that one up from what
what
oh great mils back that's fine oh really
great from the oh no no wow
five five six excellent yeah you don't
mind i got back home that's about
you you're gonna do if you walk around
new york city with an ar get shot yeah
they'll just
take out you're done and there won't be
a so
listen listen i don't understand right i
find it interesting that conservatives
are adamant about defending urban cops
who enforce unconstitutional laws
and i find it strange that the democrats
are angry with the police when they vote
for the democrats to implement these
systems
it's almost like for me being out in the
middle of nowhere
i've not had an interaction with any
cops because we're in the middle of
nowhere
we have a sheriff's department we don't
have a police department i don't got to
worry about it
you don't you don't you don't want to be
in new york because you're angry with
who you voted for
dude chicago's been electing democrats
for what 85 years
and it's working really well i think
it's almost fixed i think it's almost
fixed almost
right they're getting really close
literally literally torturing people
into false confessions
operating what they call black sites
where they kidnap people they're not
arrests they're kidnapped and they lock
them up for days and no one knows where
they went
that's what they do in chicago sounds
good great they also eat thick crust
pizza
why am i going to support those cops now
they're good cops are going to be
but chicago's a rough and tumble place
why am i i don't live there i grew up
there i didn't like it
voting didn't change anything everyone
keeps electing democrats i'm out
here's the thing you mentioned guns
earlier i just want to
make this point it's unbelievable to me
how quickly people forget i mean a
couple months ago everyone was saying
that the whole gun control discussion is
dead because we saw left wingers burning
down basically every major city in this
country
people needed to be able to protect
themselves and they were afraid and they
thought you know what i am not going to
support gun control legislation ever
then they elected joe biden uh right and
now joe all sleepy joe wants to make
sure that you can't get the firearm that
you need to protect yourself or your
family when people riot
and then we had rights again immediately
after you you had the craziest thing
about joe biden
is he wants to make fif he wants to make
50 bmg miners as an nfa item
a 50 you mean i can't have as a citizen
an anti-material rifle what if what if
an enemy helicopter
exactly no no i agree but hold on
helicopters and they will fly to your
house
so that was the next step however i do
joe biden does want to ban 50 bmg and i
do think people should be allowed to
have it
i absolutely do and so there's a lot of
things that he wants to ban he wants to
ban
um uh ar pistols essentially yeah he
wants he calls him short barrel rifles
and i wish i i wish i would have bought
one last time i had the opportunity to
make it
let's let's talk about joy behar oh yeah
she i'm really proud of her
i'm happy for her she had a really good
take this week
columbus policeman who shot mikaya
bryant could have just
shot the gun in the air oh which is this
is great this is
that's actually the first thing any uh
concealed carry instructor will tell you
no
if you're an immigrant don't even i
won't joke i won't joke about this guys
do not ever do that first of all
insanity there's no such thing as a
warning shot
there is no movies guys if you
fire a gun in the air here's the thing
the bullet doesn't keep going
and then leave the atmosphere like it
comes back down
and people die people have gotten hit by
stray bullets that were fired in the air
don't do they're they're so stupid joy
what are you talking about
are you that's like this remember joe
biden did you know
oh he's about to yeah you no actually
joel you let out two blasts you guys no
he said that that's a joke yeah about a
shotgun take a shark or now you let out
two blasts
joe he's in the air right he's like fire
off yes he said fire okay he tells his
wife she didn't need an air just get a
shotgun and fire two blasts okay
no joe to be fair if he's talking about
birdshot
you'll annoy people don't do that he was
talking about buckshot
you'll you could mildly hurt somebody
bullets you know depending on the grain
they go somewhere it's just
crazy but these these are heavier and
these can injure people seriously when
they're coming down
you don't want to fire anything into the
air because you don't know what it's
going to hit who it's going to hit what
it's going to interfere with
they land places yep in fact there's
some states where you can't actually use
certain guns for hunting because the
state's flat
so they they may have requirements about
what what weapons you can use
i think new jersey i could be wrong is
like shotguns only
because a high velocity round is going
to be it's a flat surface it's going to
travel really really far
you don't know it's going to hit you
can't track it properly
what we're hearing okay let me just
reiterate joy behar let me read you what
you said
the view co-host joy behar and sunny
hostin agreed on thursday that the
police officer who shot and killed
mikaya bryant in columbus ohio
had the option to de-escalate instead of
using deadly force
behar suggested the officer could have
just shot his gun in the air instead of
aiming at the 16 year old
quote he said the cop had no choice and
my feeling is i don't know if that's
true or not
behar said i really can't figure it out
anymore it seems to me in a situation
i've looked at the tape and i still
can't figure it out shoot the gun in the
air
warning tase a person shoot them in the
leg shoot them in the behind stop them
somehow
but if only the solution is to kill a
teenager there's something wrong with
this
lady's never been to a range in her life
never dude first of all does she think
this is a western
and like the sheriff just comes out and
fires his gun into the air and then
everyone stops no
no no she thinks the cop comes out spins
his glock
fires and it shoots the knife out of
exactly she stops
this is really this is really hilarious
when they say things like shoot him
didn't joe biden say [ __ ] in the leg or
something
yeah well we the weapons experts at the
view have unfortunately
let us down for the first time that i
can think of
i know at the view i'ma look i
understand everyone's probably
commenting saying tim doesn't know what
he's talking about with guns no no i'll
fully admit i am not a gun actor by any
means i missed a guy who recently bought
guns and i can tell you this lady's nuts
yeah it's kind of like but to be honest
like ripping on joy behard's view of
guns is sort of like shooting fish in a
barrel that's above your head
oh got her there am i right got jokes
that's right ladies and gentlemen
freedom tunes all right check it out
this is why we have these insane laws
that make no sense
and i'm like you know what man i'm
sitting on twitter when people are
talking about gun control
and it's just like have you ever seen
have you
when was the last time you went to grade
school and you were just like there for
some reason you saw like all the little
kids
you know like fifth grade or whatever
and they're all really dumb
what that's rude why would you say that
because because kids
i'm not saying that to say like kids
aren't
smart they lack knowledge yeah of course
experience so
you'll hear from a lot of kids a lot of
really dumb things like it's so dumb
like
there's there's like a hundred houses
and like 10 homeless people but like a
bunch of the houses are empty so just
put the homeless people in the houses
like it's so dumb
i've seen college students share that
one that's right and then you say
something that's an adult opinion
apparently houses have to be maintained
and someone has to pay for the utilities
you can't just put people under the rug
and expect them to go away but little
kids say things like this
how come if there's like starving people
we just don't like give them food like
it's so
dumb tim if if we have here's the if if
we
print money why do we ever need to tax
people why don't we just print money to
pay for stuff forever
aoc advocating for deficit spending
she's like we can just print the money
to pay for them surprised yeah mmt it's
beautiful
yeah yeah so going on twitter during a
gun control argument
man wow it's just like my favorite meme
is the one where they say no
self-respecting hunter would use an
ar-15 which is not true it's the most
popular hunting rifle in the country but
not even that
but i'm like here's a photograph of an
ar-15 chambered in 450 bushmaster quite
literally for hunting
like what do you mean it's this round
was made for hunting
but these people just don't they
literally don't know anything anything
ever boy are they arrogant so they'll
tell you to do something
illegal extremely dangerous it's amazing
to me they're like the cops
should be held accountable and they
should fire their guns in the air
all right so so we've got people rioting
we've got racist police officers
and we've also got gun control how like
how can we have all three at once that's
why
look look that's why i'm not um i don't
understand the
the people opposed to abolishing the
place at this point because this these
cities voted for them but what do you
mean by i guess what do you mean by
abolishing the police like i think it
would be good to have a police board so
i'm i'm for some minimal state you know
let the let the cops prevent people from
murdering each other
let's clarify right like we have a
sheriff's department out here and
they're pretty all right
they're they're they're they're they're
pretty good uh you don't have a lot of
interactions with them you call them
when you need assistance on certain
matters
and yeah you might get pulled over by
state trooper you might get pulled over
by a sheriff's deputy or something
but it's not the same as like a police
force in a major metropolitan city now
interesting
my point is it's not so much about
whether i think it's a good deal i think
it's a bad idea
i think these cities are going to have a
lot of problems yeah i'm also
of the mind that you should have
responsibility for yourself we should
have a right to keep and bear arms
so the left says abolish police i say i
think that's a really bad idea and
you're not going to like that and they
say
shut up bigot we're abolishing the
police i'll be like all right well
this is the thing i got a gun in my
holster and be like you do your thing
and i am all about
demilitarizing the police but when you
turn your city into a war zone i don't
know what you expect
yeah it's interesting too because
demilitarized i guess i i brought this
up before a similar point someone kind
of
they made a good point back like what
does that mean with a discussion about
militarization of the police
we see m raps we see cops in armor
and actually that's a good thing you
know why why
the more options officers have the less
lethal occurrences will happen
if an officer is fully armored and
they have less lethal rounds they have
you know sponge rounds or tear gas that
means they're not using live ammunition
that makes sense
okay that's fair if the cop also is
armored and feels like he's more likely
to be safe
he's less likely to use lethal rounds
against another person he won't fire his
gun into the air
well right so imagine you have so we i
mean we had this story just a moment ago
about these cops resigning
from their emergency response team now
they're saying they're gonna have to use
regular field officers to to fill that
gap
if you have a regular cop who's just
wearing their shirt with a vest
and they have their gun and a taser
that's it what are their options
a riot breaks out and they're like i
can't tase these people from range
and they're all throwing molotovs my
only choice is lethal force or nothing
some cops might run away okay then you
get no enforcement you give a cop a
shield
some armor and some sponge rounds and
now they're gonna
mostly nuisance people they're less
lethal because they can kill
but look it's it's better to have the
option
you know what i mean yeah that's fair
yeah so i guess the idea is
when we're uh giving cops 50 bmg and all
those crazy weapons the other argument
is
what do the cops do when someone else
comes out with something like that it
doesn't mean they use it all the time
but it's interesting what people mean by
militarization i feel like
the last time i brought that up i didn't
really thought about it i think you know
it wasn't
i was i was coming from a very ignorant
place they're less likely to make a
like a a decision out of fear probably
if they're if they're armed with a teeth
but if they're ordered to fire then
we're in
way more trouble armed with what sponge
rounds
i don't know also bazookas rocket
launchers but they don't have to who
knows
they don't have those things i mean do
you know what's in their trunk what's in
the apc
i really don't think they're bringing
flamethrowers
i mean weapons well hold on there's an
argument to be made for temp
flamethrowers
though of course there is yeah no
they're actually there's not an
assistant
like you're heavily mildly pelosi wanted
crew served machine guns
remember that what yeah you remember
that nancy pelosi said
in dc she wanted crew served was it
called crew service machine guns
yeah like mountain machines see like
yeah like that's terrifying
in a city yeah it's not going to go
through a building yeah yeah
that's insanity nancy pelosi should be
kept far away from gun laws after saying
something like that
what she thinks it's re i don't even
think that's reason her and joy behar i
think should write the next piece of
legislation
they should get together have nancy on
the view i'm sure
i remember 1970 i wasn't there for it
but uh
may 4th 1970 at kent state university
the national guard was ordered i don't
know if they were ordered but they fired
on crowded college kids killed four
so it's not out of the question that
cops will open fire and if
they're heavily armed that could be
devastating is it the point what i'm
saying then
is to make sure that when they come out
there they have armor shields and less
lethal rounds
that is defensively yeah but that's not
necessarily like when you say militarize
that that's way more broad than just
shields and this is and this is a
question because i've covered this stuff
for over a decade and i've not seen an
instance
where there have been uh i i i'll put
this way
most instances when the police come out
and they're in gear and they're in m
wraps they have less lethal
there are usually one or two cops i'll
see with live ammo
we've seen those happen but for the most
part having a rifle is not
militarization
we're talking about the armor the
fatigues and the m raps and i'm like
that's actually not that big a deal cops
have had rifles since what the
the 90s when the armor piercing bankrop
the robbers or the armor-piercing rounds
were shooting at cops
and so then they were like we need swat
teams now they escalated tactics
but the the militarization i often see
it's like they were given an
arm you know an armored personnel
carrier and i'm kind of like
so like i don't know like what are they
gonna do they're gonna ram somebody with
it i mean they shouldn't
i think well i think that the concern
for a lot of people is a growing police
state
yeah and so that's why that frightens
them if there comes a day when the
government really does clamp down on our
rights or they come to take our guns
comes a day you say yeah if there comes
a i know if eventually at some
unthinkable point in an unforeseeable
future far down the line
um the police are weaponized against the
citizenry people are afraid of them
having
and i totally understand that you know i
got to tell you man
when i see these donald trump supporters
and they're posting memes from michael
malus about how the police
will absolutely seize your guns from
yeah i'm like dude
the cops have lost a lot of support from
the right a lot
well especially after these right and
part of it was like in a lot of these
left-wing
run cities they wouldn't really let the
police do anything to prevent the
rioting
from from occurring but also they did
choose to follow those orders at the
same time
and so a lot of conservatives feel very
betrayed that's right
yeah so that's my attitude right now
right the the police
out here in the middle of nowhere the
sheriffs they alright
they're cool they don't got any beef in
fact you know west virginia is a
constitutional carry so there's no
issues
you can walk around not you can you can
drive in your car with your passenger
like holding their weapon
you can walk down the street with your
weapon and you know the crazy thing is
nothing happens nobody's going around
like no one hurt anybody
no one's shooting anybody in fact i
mentioned this before
when i'm driving through west virginia
and i see all these houses with there's
no cops anywhere and i'm just like
none of these people are worried about
getting robbed yeah you know why
the crime rates are armed to the teeth
the crime rate's actually high
wait where is this in west virginia that
uh there's a lot of problem with drug
use
oh okay yes what about the violent crime
rate i don't entirely know for sure
but i do know so i'm i'm in like some
facebook groups for like some west
virginia places
and there are people who are like you
know there was one someone posted
something where they were like
someone did something in my yard and
then other people were like you know
watch out because someone might be
casing the joint
and then they'll laugh one guy's like
man i wish it was my house
oh my gosh and i'm like calm down
gentlemen chill chill
chill there right now you don't want to
have to be in that situation yeah you
don't want to deal with
with legal laws you know what like you
want to deal with legal
lawsuits cops and all that stuff but the
attitude out there
is like don't you come on my property
yeah that's what nobody does
it comes out so it's a really
interesting argument for the anarchists
to be completely honest
left or right i don't care that in these
places where people are armed
not a lot of cops and this specific
place i'm talking about
so look let's let's be real there is
more respect for the second amendment in
the anti-autonomous zone
than there is in the outlying democrat
city no joke
hands down 100 in the chas
they like guns and they were using them
and killing kids with them it's messed
up but you gotta admit
that for better or for worse those
people were like we should be allowed to
have guns
i've seen a lot of these leftists argue
we should be allowed to have guns yeah
i've seen a lot of marks
yeah yeah i know a lot of a lot of the
sort of true believer lefties are very
much in favor of gun rights it's more
the corporate democrats who oppose that
and it's a losing issue for them
i hope so i mean generally here's the
thing when they get into power and they
can have somebody like joe biden
in a position to sign executive orders
or push for legislation
then they'll get their way usually but
the american people don't want to vote
for that
the american people when polled gun
control measures tend to be really
unpopular on both sides
they're more unpopular on the right but
they're unpopular on the left as well
this is this is where my
my thinking has brought me i don't live
in new york i don't care if they want to
abolish their police
that's for the people of new york to
decide if the people who like the cops
don't vote or don't stand up and defend
the cops and keep voting for democrats
to defend them then
it's going to happen yeah you know what
i won't live there i'm also of the
opinion i should have a right to keep
and bear arms and i should be
responsible for my own safety
i shouldn't have to call someone else to
protect me i should be able to be
reasonable and responsible when it comes
to my own safety which means
i'm not going to use a a steel core
rifle round in a city it's ridiculous
you want to use something like hollow
point or fragile or that's
that's not going to over penetrate or
you want to use a shotgun
you want to use something reasonable in
your home for defense because it's your
responsibility
whatever comes at your weapon is your
responsibility i shouldn't have to call
someone and say quick
be the guardian for me and get here an
hour while someone's breaking into my
home
that includes new york that includes
where i live so i'm like if they're
gonna abolish police
where i live i'm already responsible for
my own safety i don't i don't rely on
government here's the thing even if
you're in the city it takes what like an
average 20 minutes for them to get to
wherever you are so
you might not realize it but you're
pretty much responsible for your safety
wherever you are and the supreme court
actually ruled that the police are not
responsible for your safety you cannot
sue your local police department if a
cop doesn't get there in time to protect
you
and what are what are the police doing
in a lot of these riots they ain't
surrounding
the houses they're surrounding the
government buildings and the police
departments
so look if you live in a city and you
like your police department
and and you want to keep them i respect
it 100 considering i don't live there
i'm not going to tell your community how
to live if you live in an area that
votes against your own interests and
you're in a losing battle you can choose
to stay
advocate for what you believe fight for
you know keeping your department strong
and funded
that's cool too i respect that a whole
lot taking a lot of risk to make sure
you can try and help your community
fight what you believe in is respectable
um or maybe you
feel like it's a losing battle and
you're like i'm just gonna leave and and
go somewhere where
my views my rights are respected and
find like-minded people
if you do that just don't vote for the
same idiots who ruined where you lived
because the only thing you got to keep
in mind yeah and then for the people who
live in these places
make sure these people who come aren't
going to vote for
idiots yeah i'm concerned with like the
way the media is framing the police
because
it's demoralizing and disrupting and
making destroying the the civil
defense force basically that we have the
united states the police and what's
going to happen
if that continues is that police will
continue to resign
private police will be hired in their
place or more military
militarized federal police will come in
that's right and then that will spread
from city to city
and even if you flee and go into the
jungle of the united states the hills or
whatever with your guns
private police federal police it's i
mean it's it's a plague so you want to
stop it
now ian well ian you're freaking about
the social workers
come on wouldn't you love to call like
police hut
or mick police or how about policies and
policies junior but i'm not a subscriber
how about old country police
i would but i wasn't subscribed golden
police i wasn't paying the 7.99 a month
to get my i'm not a fan of private
policing
no not i have no problem no problem to a
certain degree with private security but
the massive private security companies
do a lot more than just protecting a
small you know
a small business or something the the
issue with private policing
in a large scale in my opinion is going
to be their their beholden to the people
who are
hiring them not to you no not to the
government right
and so i suppose they're still the
judiciary which can keep them in line
right
they have to justify what they do and
how they do it they'll still be
constrained by the law
tech made but who will enforce it
another private you know so imagine
mick police you know accidentally you
know shoots shoots a kid
and so then police king comes in and
then they're like we're gonna arrest the
mick police guy
and then someone calls police hut and
they're like you're both under arrest
for trespassing and then they're all
like
what are they what are we gonna do and
police would be top dog just to be clear
police
yeah no i think police bell would would
would come in with a mountain dew and
they'd be like all right whatever you
say bro
i don't know how insidious this whole
thing is if it's actually like some
conspiracy from the chinese government
to disrupt the united states people and
if if that is the case which i have no
idea if it is or not
i could see these private police coming
in and then all of a sudden all this
anti-policing sentiment just is kind of
gone they're not complaining anymore
because they're happy to see this
authoritarian police state
because that's what the chinese
government the ccp wants
to happen in the united states to weaken
it
yeah and i think the ultimate result of
the police resigning
is we're getting ever closer to divorce
i won't say peaceful because i don't
know what that means it won't be
peaceful but what do you think listen
listen to this you're talking about
people will flee the cities right
what do you think happens when the
police are all just fractured crime is
already skyrocketing
and then a bunch of these people start
heading out to like nebraska you think
these guys in rural nebraska are going
to be like come on in guys and yeah
destroy
it or they're going to be like dude do
you remember when the city's back where
you came remember when they were talking
about going into the suburbs last summer
and they did i remember everyone was
posting like man if they come into my
neighborhood they did it
what suburbs well where i lived in the
philly area they were very close within
miles
really the helicopters were i could see
them in the sky really okay
not in my area man we i'm on the other
side of the river yeah in philly
and then i'm like i think we're fine
they're not gonna cross the bridge and
then i said here's sirens and
helicopters yeah i remember
that yeah i'm like tim's like you know
what i need guns this is it
yeah no joke was that one you decided
that i don't think that was it didn't
hurt
it didn't hurt though there was a night
that we were out like on the deck and
the helicopter flew by we were like
and you can hear all the sirens and we
were like why are they here
oh my goodness sleepy suburbs in chicago
they did it in chicago
they showed up in tiny suburbs in the
middle of nowhere michael church that's
right
okay i do remember this michael tracy
drove around the country and he went to
small towns you never heard of that had
riots
that's right and the media was like
they're not gonna go to the suburbs and
they did
they all over the place i remember this
ago because and i remember for so long
conservatives
conservatives were like well don't write
why would you write in your own cities
and they're like oh yeah good point
let's go outside
it's like guys why did you say that yeah
in
chicago there was an alderman these are
like neighborhood politicians
on a leaked video cussing out mayor lori
lightfoot he's like you need to check
your attitude because
she apparently raised the bridges which
forced all the riders
into the neighborhoods yeah like where
people live he was like let him have the
shopping district at least like
like we don't want to write but don't
send them to where we live and she was
like no we gotta put the comment we
gotta protect the commerce
so they went to the neighborhoods i knew
people in chicago who were shocked to
find out that there were rioters
in their suburb 40 miles outside the
city why were they there
they just that's what their mission was
i guess their plan
so it spreads all over my my the one
thing i've been saying is i think what's
possible is
you who who was it who's talking about
the bundys was it michael mills
man i don't remember it was i think so
yeah that guy gets too many shout outs
well that's a good point he's like i
think it was michael's the the bundys
when the the the bureau oh it's jim
winston it was jim hansen you see
we just inadvertently shut up michael
shout out to michael malus got his free
plug
jim hanson was talking about you
remember the bundy thing bundy ranch
yeah the bunny ranch yeah the
the blm showed up that's the bureau of
land management
yeah you had a bunch of you know
right-wing dudes being like
feds get out so what happens if the
crime is escalating
and then we start seeing more of the
black lives matter stuff trying to show
up in these small towns
there's already video where like some
neighborhood a bunch of dudes who live
there just chased out anti-fun like
shoved them and they're like running
antivirus i remember that right yeah
what happens
when it gets bad the cops are completely
demoralized and fractured
crime is skyrocketing it already is and
then these people start coming to
a small town the local people are going
to start standing at the
you know the state highway in front of
their town armed being like stop what's
your business
turn around and get out and then they're
going to get called racist by the media
and they won't care
yeah hopefully and then is how's the
federal government going to enforce that
drones they won't be able to drones
can't even do it
look what people don't understand when
these leftists especially are like
do you really think a person can go up
against the federal government they have
cruise missiles it's like uh dude you
think a cruise missile can occupy a
street corner
you think you can enforce laws with just
one cruise missile yeah you can't
there's 330 million people there's 220
million adults
we operate on an honor system of people
agreeing to work together and having
confidence
in our law and and order we we all agree
on things we should or shouldn't do
we have a shared community and shared
culture to a great degree
and it's being eroded and that's when
things break down the new york times
wrote an article saying that political
sectarianism is getting really really
is getting a lot worse in this country
yeah and it's true we're at the point
where
the democrats some of them are so
adamant
on defunding the police or proving
the the cons wrong that they defended
child knife
fights yeah what happens when you have a
kid
in a school and some leftist shows up
and runs for school board gets elected
and they start saying
well children should be allowed to have
knife fights your kid's there
and then some kid picks up a knife i'm
not saying it will happen
maybe it's just silly but we've seen
silly rhetoric like abolish the police
actually become more mainstream there's
a new york times op-ed
where they said yes we mean abolish the
police and you get these prominent
democrats saying no no
no one's saying that it's not real
abolish the police is not real
and now they're saying it more than ever
now after chauvin is found guilty on all
counts
did they say we did it we won we finally
have justice no obama said that's not
justice
aoc the aoc said that's not justice and
then one black lives matter activist in
minnesota said we will never be
satisfied
quote wow none of us saw that coming
right remember when we talked about this
like two weeks ago and we're like riots
it's good it doesn't matter what happens
riots right that's what i see happening
we just played that song earlier before
the show riot there's no
justice for for floyd he died
there is no justice for the dead they're
gone but the justice is for the people
that survive
and i don't think is it
is it morally right to convict derek
chovin
on two counts of murder and a kind of
manslaughter that's
i don't know uh we don't have a system
to judge if you don't know
then you have reasonable doubt morality
like we don't
really have a morality in our law if you
if you
listen ian if you can you say to me
definitively derrick chauvin should be
convicted on all counts
beyond beyond a doubt in my mind no not
from what i know
that's so that that's the standard we
have the standard we have isn't
i'm not sure so i better convict him
it's i'm not sure so that means he can't
be convicted
we had a juror who she was an alternate
she just spoke out for
with cbs and her attitude was very much
the defense didn't prove their case
i'm like wow the defense didn't have to
prove it so is that an appeal
is that right to appeal i mean if the
jurors or she was an alternate she
didn't actually weigh in on the verdict
so but she said in my mind he was guilty
that the prosecution had a great case
and i think i think her her opinion is
uh it's a legitimate opinion
she did say that she was worried that no
matter what she did people were gonna
get mad at her so you know
when she said something like that it was
as close as we we're gonna get to
an emission admission that the riots
played a role in the in the in the
verdict
because you might say to yourself look i
want to be really careful what i say
because i know
that no matter what i say everyone will
get mad and they say okay
what's the worst case scenario if you
piss off the conservatives
they'll insult you on the internet
what's the worst case scenario if you
piss off the leftists
they'll call your work they'll make fake
stories about you
they'll threaten you you'll lose your
job you'll never be able to work again
you'll get kicked off the internet so
when someone says i'm worried everyone
will get mad yeah but you know who
they're scared of they're not scared
who are going to roll over and be like
oh you're dumb no they're scared of the
left
so you know this woman basically she
basically said that
it was an emotional thing she said she
watched the video and she cried
and the prosecution said at the end
they're closing arguments
you know trust your eyes you saw it you
saw it you know
you know what happened the defense had a
great
closing argument like three hours long
and he kept saying you know he
they were instructed the state needs to
prove beyond a reasonable doubt if
there's any doubt you cannot convict and
they were like
but you didn't prove your case she said
that the defense over-promised
maybe maybe the defense need to be very
explicit and say
we're not going to prove derek shelton's
innocent today we're only going to prove
to you that
the state doesn't know what happened and
that's it
instead it's what we get it's disturbing
that there was a girl
on the on the jury or at least as an
alternate that was crying and making
decisions out of her
emotions that's how that's how people
work though that's
that's true of all juries yeah you can't
expect people to be spock
i have weighed the evidence and i have
concluded it was not it would not be
morally just
to convict this man and then you get you
know bones being like come on jim don't
lock him up
we got to do the right thing another
star trek reference
shout out but oh but oh oh oh gee star
trek shout out to someone i'm a
doctor i got to say it spock was wrong
most of the time
there's a really great article there's a
really great article that went over
every prediction spock ever made in an
episode about probabilities of what
might happen and he's wrong 83
of the time because the show wanted
suspense so spock would be like
there was a 79 chance that we will
explode on impact
let's do it anyway and then they'd make
it here's the thing the probability
really was that high they just got
really lucky every time
every single time yeah divine
intervention yeah well don't don't
don't trash spock just because they got
lucky
can we get a little bit arbitrary here
and just talk about some culture war
stuff because i
i'm just going to hard segway normally i
like to have the conversation flow
better
but we have this article about ben
shapiro that i'm just yeah honestly okay
we're not going to talk about shapiro i
heard he bought a bunch of what that was
that was the big story that was today's
news cycle
here i was making cartoons about maxine
waters when what i really should have
been paying attention to was who's going
to home depot
ben shapiro okay folks i'm at home depot
right now i'm gonna buy this i'm gonna
buy this two by four and i'm just gonna
just gonna beat a small child with it
mercilessly mercilessly we had this
whole conversation before the show that
was very hilarious
we were laughing nonstop for like 20
minutes before the show joking about
like why ben shapiro went to home depot
to buy wood and why he was like showing
it off
and he's like okay he's
i was the one with two hours of sleep
tim you don't have an excuse
no it's like okay honestly here's why i
support home depot okay because they
still have child
they still allow child labor which is
american and it's it's part of the free
market and
you are able to test their wood boards
to see how strong they are by just
hitting children with it
and so you just like one of them is
going to break the two by four the child
and
it's important to know if you have two
by four strong enough to to actually uh
beat a child mercilessly with it all
right gang i mean that's the news right
the story this is from forbes they say
that uh
ben shapiro took time out of his data
shop at home depot in pursuit of an
abstract culture war victory that
resulted in yet another dose of internet
humiliation i gotta be honest
no i saw the clip and it's been holding
a bag
with like a plank like a one by six
plank in it or like something
and he's like that is a great piece of
wood my friends i thought it was a joke
like i thought it was satire i was like
oh he's being silly he's doing a bit
maybe he's but then someone posted
another video where he was like i'm here
at home depot and i'm going to buy stuff
and i was like wait
is he seriously advocating like yeah but
like
it's a joke if you bought a two by four
and then made a bit about it it's not
so much a joke i guess if you're
literally documenting your experience
going to home depot and advocating for
people to go there see i don't know see
i would do that as a troll
i'd be like let's see what the internet
gets upset about i bet they'll get
super wound about me literally going to
a store and buying a piece of wood let's
see if we can make it happen yeah
i mean here's the thing you can
definitely say it's silly but i mean
it's good to support a business that
promotes your values
too so much so many corporate entities
are bending the knee right now so why
not support the ones who don't and i
think
here's the thing i think home depot
understands that they can't like how
many homeless people customers are woke
dude
oh no home depot wants you to come shop
at their place when you have to rebuild
their store because you got looted
i know right let me let's pull this
through for michael knows michael
knowles tweet
ben shapiro bought a plank of what is
nationally trending news
all right i i got to stop i got to stop
what's that shapiro masterfully played
yep
yeah masterfully it was it was trending
on twitter it was trending
dude ben shapiro knows how to get
pressed yes he does he's like
you know you know what i think happened
or does he just get pressed because he's
been shapiro maybe but listen
he's sitting i imagine they're all
sitting at the daily wire office
and they're like what do we do and ben's
like i bet i could literally just like
buy a plank of wood i bet like a gang
and it would be like national news it's
gonna be so big it is we're gonna we're
gonna troll the libs it's gonna be so
epic i'm gonna beat a child with a
two-by-four
home depot parking lot let me read this
i gotta hear it politics trending ben
shapiro shares a video of himself
purchasing a single wood blanket home
depot
after a coalition of black faith leaders
in georgia called for a boycott of the
company
over its unwillingness to condemn the
state's new voting law
that is the stupidest thing i have ever
read in every respect
that is amazing but i will tell you
listen
they're all these companies where like
all the ceos were like we condemn
georgia's
voting law and home depot was like i
don't know so they were like we condemn
home depot
that's dumb ben shapiro mocking them by
making a silly video
is like it's a hilarious troll by the
way i don't know if you guys
noticed but the top reply to michael
knowles tweet is from an account called
freedom tunes which you which you should
all check out
okay gang this is epic all right i got
my two by far we're gonna go own some
lives of it we're gonna own some lives
of the two by four which by which i mean
we're just gonna go we're just gonna go
beat antifa
with my two by four all right this is
this is really high quality lumber folks
i
am less than two thousand subs away from
600k
if you want to run over to freedom tunes
mash that subscribe button
check out the three cartoons we made
this week i love all of you
back to our bench apparel
gizmodo ben shapiro finally manages to
get wood
shot yeah but they're writing an article
about him
you know what i was i noticed something
didn't jimmy kimmel make fun of tucker
crosston recently
uh yeah jimmy jimmy kimmel did like a
bit making fun of tucker carlson
and then uh david pakman also did a bit
where he said that tucker crosstalk has
a psychotic break on his show
yeah i realized something they are
they're having withdrawals from trump
yeah yes 100 dude they've been having
withdrawals for a while
they had that tds turned out it was
actually just an addiction yeah
cult worship these people are i are
trump so much and now that he's gone
it's like you know donald trump was that
what was it breaking bad that that blue
meth that was trump it was this pure it
was amazing they were just like ah
and now they're like now they're now
they're pulling off like a hunter biden
digging through the carpet yeah for
parmesan cheese thinking it's crack
when you when you when you go from like
the most corrupt president in history is
incited to insurrection
and you think you're like writing great
works for the annals of history
and then you're like meant to be robot
wood
carlson left ben shapiro buying a piece
of wood
is the hunter bite and smoking parmesan
cheese of news
that's that's that's that's it i said it
that's it wow i can't believe you just
went there tim
i i'm like just it's the it's the cult
dude this cult worship i mean it's been
around
since the dawn of humanity people are
obsessed with with people
i have i've reached the conclusion that
we get the journalism that we deserve
100 100 think this is a manifestation
punishment for our sins
unironically yes like there's a reason
god's not sparing us from this that's
all
i i actually mean that i actually mean
that can i just say though like
watching the 80 million story about how
trump did something he didn't do
was like infuriating watching them
basically like rocking back and forth
with like
dark rings around their eyes digging
through digging through the carpet for
parmesan hilarious yeah
this story about veggie peter i'm just
sitting there i'm like i'm i'm here for
a man because you know we're not
struggling on this show
we're not we're not struggling for news
or topics to talk about we have a good
time
we'll talk about movies we got you know
we got some justice league stuff we can
talk about
these people are in panic mode yeah like
when they needed him they needed him he
complete remember in the dark night we
were just watching the dark knight
when the joker's like i can't kill you
you're too much fun like he's like
expressing to batman that he wants to
keep him like you complete me
that's exactly how they are with trump
except maybe trump's the joker you know
because we live in a society and he
knows it no trump's not the joker
i don't think he's trump batman he's
harvey dent dude these are pizzas
actually two-faced yeah i mean harvey
dent was a suit wearing blonde dude in
the movie
closer to trump than anything yeah and
and actually
i wouldn't say it's like a perfect but
if i had to say which character he was
it'd be harvey dent
in that he's a man of the law but he
takes things a little too far
oh you know what i mean then who is
batman is the question
who is batman it couldn't be bernie
sanders he's joking
joe biden yes 100
joe biden's the joker doesn't make any
sense the media is the joker
you think so the media was the joker
yeah because he's just too much fun he
can't kill him like the joker was trying
to
make crazy things happen because it was
fun and he was trying to shake things up
and hold on what did the joker say to
harvey dent in the hospital
if i tell the press that like a gang
banger will get shot or a truckload of
soldiers will be blown up bits
nobody cares it's all according to
planning part of the plan but if i say
one little old mayor is gonna die well
then everyone loses their minds
people love to plan if it's terrible
horrifying
yeah that doesn't sound like that that
sounds like
that sounds more like antifa the little
bit sounds like we're living in a
society
i have to stop that's such a tired joke
what's wrong with society i love it
but we get the media we deserve man we
100 percent do yeah we brought this upon
ourselves we're still consuming this
stuff
i thought that eleanor roosevelt she
said that great minds think about ideas
i don't know mediocre minds talk about
things and then like weak minds talk
about
people and why are you talking about
eleanor roosevelt ian
i fell for it how dare you you got it no
i'm kidding i'm kidding
i've heard i try to i try to stay true
to that kind of concept
in that there are a lot of people who
make youtube careers off of
talking about drama and i'm like does
anyone really care
about like when you know sometimes i'll
talk about things that are relevant to
me personally yeah
i try to avoid that and i'm like do
people tune into the show to hear about
my petty drama no they don't
i would personally i'm just saying i
would if we just did tim's drama cast
and you're like talking about everything
in your life somebody threw my beanie on
the ground
i was kicking things over he totally was
ah i'm kidding
but but you know i think about all these
people try to drag drag me or
other people in drama and i'm like let
me tell you why one of the reasons i
think
the work i do is is more successful than
many other people on youtube
doing it for longer so many people on
youtube who are in this commentary space
would single out individuals no one
really cares about to make drama because
drama content was it was easy clicks
but extrapolate that to the mainstream
media instead of telling us about
jake paul they tell us about trump well
i mean listen the jake paul
fighting uh that was actually mayweather
yeah he's gonna fight mayweather right i
think so
that's gonna be the fastest boxing match
i've ever seen yeah dude
paul's gonna take him out dude real
quick one hitter quitter man
dude i can see it it's brilliant it's
it's brilliant but
i think that's that and that's
culturally relevant like yeah one of the
best boxers ever and some crazy guy on
youtube
is going to fight him i want to watch
that that's i think
that's that's good to talk about because
it's it's a it's the best boxer you know
what i mean it's like he's like the the
main guy
and we're getting this i wouldn't say
it's the most important thing in the
world but something to talk about i
would say it is
but when you have nothing imagine if the
media only wrote about
mayweather and logan yeah logan i have
no idea
which one i'll be real with imagine if
the media wrote
7 000 stories in two weeks about just
mayweather versus
paul jake paul we'd be like this is the
stupidest thing ever what was wrong with
you right one story we got it if donald
trump
you know kicks a goat and they write a
story about it you know he did that so
he wrote a story about it if they write
eight thousand stories over four months
of like
donald trump incited insurrection the
insurrection oh the cops
blame every single goat-related injury
on donald trump they're like goats are
getting hurt more often was this because
trump kicked a goat
that's right big problem he's a friend
of goat kicking when they're like he
said it
she said it he's bad she's bad that gets
that's the bottom feeding crap
but when you say like he said it this is
why it's good let me tell you for a
while
about the ideas this is kind of what you
do with your youtube videos
or that's bad i'm going to tell you why
and then you break down the ideas
you're acknowledging the crap but you're
talking about
the process which is what what i want to
say is i think it's perfectly legitimate
to talk about donald trump i think it's
perfectly legitimate to talk about
ocasio-cortez why
they're prominent figures influencing
our country yeah sure but there are
people who are like
not prominent but they're like decently
well-known activists that become the
center
like the target for like content and
it's like you can talk about it once or
twice if it's relevant
it's not it's not something you should
focus on so heavily and we should focus
on
the ideas around these things what they
represent are you telling me to stop
making fun of ben shapiro is that what
i'm hearing no i just want you if i stop
doing ben shapiro
videos you got to blame tim that's your
guy i'm talking about
i know i'm kidding i'm kidding i'm
kidding by all means make more videos
mocking
you know okay that's ridiculous everyone
dude dude i'm so tired right now that
i'm gonna have some gaffes and joe
biden's gonna end up making cartoons
making fun of me
he's gonna be like i can't wait for that
this is okay
come on man dude joe biden just starts
roasting me he's like look at this guy
everyone's laughing the whole country is
just roasting me
let me just say that video you did
recently where it's joe biden's stutter
in class
oh yes and joe biden that quote where he
says he used to walk around
oh yeah yeah please watch the video yeah
all right guys
he actually said that this that's the
best part about so
let's keep it family friendly but he
went around black neighborhoods
saying things just watched the videos
yeah just very
very offensive a crazy it's like how can
a political leader say that and survive
like i feel like if i were which i never
would like if i were to say that as a
joke like that's you are cancelled young
man
he basically said was saying it on
ironically he basically went around
telling
he he claimed that he went yeah black
neighbors telling black men to wear
condoms and that it's not unmanly to do
so and it's like well first of all
like first of all joe you're catholic
you should know that like yes it is but
also
um could you imagine joe biden doing
that just like walking down the street i
didn't even think about that yeah joe
biden actually just going door to door
no not even like some like 40 year old
like you know black dude is leaving to
go to work he works the local bank or
whatever he's you know he's just got his
briefcase with them and then joe
is like hey hold on there man let me let
me tell you something my god
like a bag of condoms so embarrassing
yeah check out we so we've been doing a
series of videos where i will just take
joe biden's
audio and string it together into a
conversation between him and someone
else
it usually comes out pretty funny if i
and i think i'm allowed to say that i
don't think i'm laughing at my own jokes
i'm just laughing like joe biden's a
good writer and he does good comedy and
i like to turn that into cartoons
sometimes so we just did
a cartoon about aliens visiting earth
and joe biden talking with them
you all should check that one out
excellent let's let's jump into this
story my friends
you may be aware that since the death of
george floyd there's been an autonomous
zone
in minneapolis well the good news for
everybody is that
the activists have won black lives
matter is victorious chauvin was
convicted on all accounts
we can all go home uh we have peace good
run everybody
appreciate all the hard work everyone
did and uh we'll see y'all oh wait hold
on i'm sorry
they're refusing to leave the autonomous
zone
activists calling for minneapolis
autonomous zone to remain until
conclusion of remaining officers trial
well
surely then they'll leave of course yeah
probably no other officers will get in
any trouble
then there's kim potter oh yeah wait
another officer
now we have another one i will i will
mention this again just for the sake of
you know saying it
you got more second amendment rights in
the autonomous zone there than you do
in the outside outlying city i mean and
i mean like you hear these stories about
people like shooting randomly into
houses and garages
and i'm like well that's a little too
much
it's certainly more respect for gun
ownership i guess keeping the cops out
not
allowing it to be enforced so this is uh
you know
it's basically what they're doing i'm
afraid of this um this
the kent state shooting in 1970 i
brought up earlier like that was a
an unexpected tragedy and it was four
people that got killed
so like if we scale up to the weapons of
war that we have now and if the national
guard comes in with helicopter gunships
and they're like patrolling over top of
these zones
they have those loose a hellfire missile
like which they're allowed to do
if they have extra judiciary
assassination go ahead no one's going to
hell fire missile united states
like the united states under the
patriarch is allowed to do it to its own
citizens
of course they're not going to we say
they're not going to shoot kids at
college either
ian you're right they'll burn down a
home full of you know with children in
it dude
the authoritarian regime can do whatever
it wants that's the terrifying thing
but but hold on a minute you realize
that back then they had cruise missiles
and m16s and full auto and helicopter
you know gun ships and all stuff right
yeah but they didn't have the the tech
not like the tracking mechanisms that
they have now
so you're saying they also didn't have
the patriot act you're worried about
like a captain america winter soldier
scenario where they have gunships that
can just target people
and then kill all the undesirables no
i'm just afraid of the next generation
of the may 4th
uh shoot massacre of the college kids
they were out on a
peaceful protest through probably
throwing rocks at the national guard
doesn't need to happen
because they already control the lines
of communication they already control
they
they know everything about you they just
they have control over everything but
like you were saying they're spying to
an insane degree the bundy ranch thing
where they were like turn around go home
arm people the atf went out there and
and decided we're not going to blm
yeah but bureau yeah if some of that
happened again
what's to say that they decide not to
turn around and go back this time
well the conclusion of the bundy thing i
suppose the conclusion or one of them
was that they killed a guy they killed
one of the friends of the bundys
my you know you want to know what i'm
worried about
you you made a good point a moment ago
when i said the
the activists are saying they won't
leave the autonomous zone until the four
until the remaining officers trials
conclude and you said
yeah probably nothing wrong will go with
any other officers here's the best part
most of these cities are bringing in
cadets to handle this stuff
so if you if you've got a 26-year
veteran of the force kim potter
and she is involved in this what do you
think someone who's a week out of the
academy is going to do exactly that
makes things he's going to be like it's
my first right what do i do
well remember two of those officers
involved in george floyd's death were
rookies right
right out of the academy we're going to
see more of the same it's going to get a
whole lot worse
yep and they're going to need a
justification see look what these police
are doing you know i find the funniest
though
i'm i just i you're you decide to be a
cop right now
like we're seeing mass retirements and
resignations and
you are joining the police department
dude i gotta be honest if it were me
i would rather live in a tent down by
the river
and fish for food in my bare feet like a
hobbit
then literally join a police department
because they're using cadets in
albuquerque albuquerque for instance
they're training cadets
in riot control like dude you're going
to get a guy who's like a few months out
of the academy
and they're going to be like well black
lives matter is rioting it's the summer
of
of peaceful protest and this dude's
going to make a mistake
inexperienced and then they're going to
be like see this proves it
even the new officers are bad it can't
be reformed
and then guess what dude i would not be
surprised if we see a bunch of
rookies end up in prison and they're
going to be put in a jumpsuit they're
going to be shackled and they're going
to part walk
and the left is going to cheer for it
who would choose to do that for 20 20
28 an hour i guess 28 is better than 15
huh
yeah i mean it's horrible and crime is
going to grow
go continue to go up likely and as you
mentioned you're going to have rookies
policing people more often because the
older folk are stepping down the
experienced officers and that is going
to be a recipe for disaster
that's right that's all i have to say
about that this is exactly what they're
asking
it's what they want this is what they
want to happen and i'm not convinced i
don't think they have any regard for the
rule of law
i think they just want power as far as
i'm convinced they want authoritarianism
what do you do if you don't have cops
how does your just society
second amendment okay so your society is
what i'm saying you know i don't know
out in the middle of nowhere where
everyone has the right to keep and bear
arms right and it's
like to a great degree or more respected
they don't have this kind of stuff going
on
it's true well to be fair people also
live further apart and you have less of
the french exactly
like you don't have the population look
look in
in some of these areas it's it's it's
not like as dense as manhattan but it's
it's it's about neighbors look when i
lived in miami
we had a five acre property we still had
neighbors fairly close
and we had problems with dogs we had to
go to the neighbors and be like yo your
dog
we had a bunch of guns well no no not
down there but people
could have a bunch of guns it's florida
so florida's like pretty good combos
wild west
but the point i'm making is you can be
out in these in these places and not
deal with this stuff
so if there's no cops in these cities i
don't think it'll get bad because you
have a lot of crime elements that you
don't have
but maybe if people have the right to
keep and bear arms because the cops are
gone and can't no one can enforce that
you know i don't know maybe it'll be
better off or they continue to strip
people of their right to keep and bear
arms and then you just have these
rioters and the mob going around bossing
folks around and they get their way
across the country you know what i gotta
stop
i'm gonna i'm gonna give you a
prediction that i don't want to come
true but i think
is obvious the reason why it's gonna get
really bad
first new cadets being brought in to
help deal with riots that's gonna lead
to a lot more accidents
and tragedies it's gonna result in an
escalation of the riots and an
escalation of the resignations
regular citizens are going to say i'm
going to protect myself
rioters rump about a suburb some dude
comes out of his house says get off my
property they start throwing bricks he
goes pop pop pop
yeah and then they make laws that strip
people their guns and then the drone
ships come in
like that that's the that's okay i don't
see that i mean maybe in ten
five years after that if some guy comes
out sec 2a guys like pop pop pop and
because writers are in his neighborhood
and he gives them an execute the
government an excuse
as to why it's dangerous that for
citizens to have guns red flag laws are
needed but there's no police
well the point is if the police all
resign because they're being locked up
they'll use the feds
and then the the feds can't maintain
like you you don't you don't understand
man
there's not enough federal law
enforcement to go to every city and have
that and maintain this it's not possible
the atf absolutely could not handle it
if the police weren't there to enforce
gun laws how many atf agents yeah
that's 100 true so there's interest
really that's it i think that's what
i saw so the atf actually only has the
capability to process
five to ten thousand cases per year
right so
if every state or not even every state
just a handful of states decided they
weren't going to enforce federal gun
control laws
which they're doing there's nothing that
the atf could do and this is not
unprecedented left-wing states do this
all the time that's what a sanctuary
city is
they started legalizing uh drugs while
they were still federally legal
right so when you get to the point where
cops all leave
and no one can enforce gun laws you're
gonna have the people like i mentioned
in chicago who are good honest
you know working families but they want
guns to protect themselves and they do
so illegally under the chicago's laws
which i don't think should i think it's
unconstitutional
but if the cops are all gone then no
one's gonna enforce that
then when the riots come out this guy's
going to be like ain't coming near my
kids and they're going to be like screw
you yeah they're going to throw a rock
and he's going to go get back get back
we've already seen in like portland a
few years ago a guy
drew his gun on some on some of the
black lives matter protesters who's
backing away get away from me
they arrested him well you've already
seen the mccloskeys yeah i was just
about to bring up the mccloskeys
so what comes next the riots are
if they if they continue to get worse
and the cops continue to resign
we have cadets but i think cadets open
up a huge possibility of risk because
these
these rookies are my opinion more likely
to go to prison
absolutely they're not going to have the
defense they're not going to
unfortunately not have the skill they're
not going to have the experience
they're going to trip and fall they're
going to panic and shoot somebody
and then the city is going to be like
they risen with you they won't know to
shoot their gun in the air that's chase
right dude you got seniority
you've been a department for decades and
the city is like we will sacrifice you
at a moment's notice
yeah you think they're gonna do anything
for a rookie no they're gonna be like
bro you just got here we even pay you
yet we don't care
to the wolves with you son and then
they're gonna turn around and say like
see
we are we arrested and charged him with
murder and then this like
26 year old or 28 year old guy's going
to be like i'm going to prison i guess
that's right it's illegal to be a cop
because they want you to arrest somebody
but you can't use force to arrest them
because if you do they might get hurt or
die and it's your fault
so you're better off just saying sir
would you would you like to be arrested
no okay please have a nice day and carry
on with your
your knifing spree speaking of knifing
spree to tie this back to what we're
talking about earlier
i'm afraid that if people aren't able to
get guns and there are fewer police
we're gonna see a lot more stabbing like
we've had 100 different stories in the
last two days
of kids stabbing each other with knives
so people are going to take like boiling
oil or hot water or
knives and all this stuff way word i
acid maybe but no absolutely
stuff that you have on hand in your
house to defend yourself
like that i don't see this ever in any
way being a good ending
so um no that asset attacks do happen in
london i'm looking at the numbers right
now i remember doing a video on this a
while ago when we were talking about gun
control everyone talks about a peaceful
um london is or england is i mean in
2017 there were 472 acid attacks
that's insane that's just in london now
that number has been decreasing 2018
only had 310 in 2019 only had 123. i
wonder what those numbers look like post
lockdown
uh crime rates have gone up here i
wouldn't be surprised if they went up
there as well and people don't have
firearms to protect themselves
well in these places without firearms
like for example sweden you know what's
happened when they took the guns out
uh the violent crime didn't go away it
got bigger and they started to have
grenade attacks
oh my goodness people don't stop wanting
to kill each other when you take their
guns away they'll just get more creative
when i went to sweden
uh it was only a few months before i'd
gotten there that someone threw a
grenade onto a balcony killing an
eight-year-old english tour
was it was a the tourist family it was
an eight-year-old kid
i think that was the story and they
threw the grenade on the balcony blew up
and uh kid died there's a lot of grenade
attacks in sweden i think they have the
highest grenade attacks per capita
outside an established war zone yeah
it's comparable that's unbelievable
and this is why people people will try
to use numbers
about gun deaths or mass shootings
specifically to make these comparisons
between the united states and other
countries
first of all even if you did have a like
to like comparison like it would be
better to
look at states compared to other
countries the united states is massive
but also it's not really a fair
comparison you should just be looking at
massacres
or mass killings generally machetes and
because yeah because you haven't solved
the problem if
just as many people per capita or more
are dying as a result of massacres or
having violent crimes committed against
them but they just happen to not be
attacked with the use of a firearm yeah
it's not an improvement
it is 100 a human nature problem and a
culture problem
maybe uh maybe it's time to get out of
cities
yeah 100 and i think we all agree on
that get out of cities basically
it's so much better to be completely
honest you know one of the challenges
back in the day was like can you get
good internet
i got to be honest it is difficult but
uh it's getting better
you know i i think getting easier
especially with starlink elon musk
that project's gonna be it's gonna
change everything you know what i think
would totally own us tim would just own
us cons
if all the left wingers
us cons if if all the left wingers
stayed in the cities and didn't leave
and vote in other places to prove us
wrong
about how great their policies are gonna
work there that would really i would cry
they'd keep me up at night they'd be
like dang they sure showed us and then
all the dumb
conservatives uh all the dumb
conservatives just come out
leave the cities yes start going to
places where your vote will actually
count
in matter every conservative needs to go
to texas
every single one including us yeah
here's the thing well texas
pass is that legislation which protects
people from social media
real estate prices are gonna well i
think i said this that uh you know
will chamberlain brought up texas is
working on a bill i think was introduced
that would
if you're a citizen a resident of texas
says if you're a resident
and you get banned from any social media
platform because of your political views
you can get an injunction and have your
account restored
so there's questions about how that will
work with the first amendment because
private companies have first member
rights as well
if they pass that though i think we
might instantly relocate
yeah you might be like texas why am i
not in texas
let's get i'm not turning blue uh but
that's exactly why i need to go there
and start voting
stop it start voting yeah yeah go to
texas become a citizen there yeah
start citizen i'll be a citizen of texas
change my residency
a resident of texas yeah resident sorry
well that's a constitutional carry
one yeah i i i didn't realize that in
texas you actually need like a handgun
license
and you have to do like a course yeah i
was surprised that is surprising to me
i thought the joke was that when you go
buy liquor they give you a gun yeah
exactly he's the family guy
yeah apparently not sad apparently it's
more like west virginia and then you
fire it into the air like joy behar told
you joyce said too
and no one gets hurt just act like
yosemite sam you know he had the right
idea yeah
and then you spin the revolver then you
go
and you spin the revolver and put it
back into the holster your glock
he pulls it out and he spins it and
shoots the knife someone actually
tweeted that i got like 700 retweets
they were like he could have just shot
the knife out of her hand
do you know like do you know what guns
are like
do you know what a knife is like yeah
yeah which concept do i need to explain
to you
for you to know that that doesn't make
sense when where she was the knife
the victim was in front of the knife he
would have shot the victim several times
to try and get the knife dude this is
like people really do think it's the
matrix
they do you can just like why don't they
just dodge the bullets why don't why
don't police just dodge bullets when
they get shot
i genuinely don't think that anyone
actually watched the video because of
the commentary we're getting
absolutely insane they weren't looking
at the angle of the perp versus the
victim like there's a direct line
between the two there's no way around it
they don't care i know they don't but
you know what i care about
super chat they do my friends if you
haven't already get your super chats in
we're going to read your own your
comments so smash that like button
comment it helps the channel and go to
timcast.com become a member
for exclusive segments we'll have a
bonus segment coming up at about 11 p.m
for all of our members we
we have these up frequently in a massive
library of tons of amazing content and i
i gotta tell you
you guys really need to check out last
night's members only with charlie
duff because he got real serious and he
told us about something he saw when he
was down there at 9 11 reporting
and it made me just like these
journalists man i shouldn't even give
them that word these these people are
sociopaths
the story he described to me i don't i
don't want to say it on youtube because
it's it's gruesome what these what these
people were doing check it out
if that's something you know i'm warning
you now it's like a serious segment
where you talk a lot about the media
it's a bit long but um
definitely check it out let's read some
super chats the civic nationalist says
what is your guy's opinion on this there
are only three crimes
causing physical harm to someone taking
property and murder
god save the queen long live britain the
sun has not yet set rule britannia
forevermore oh
three crimes causing physical harm to
someone taking property and murder
um i don't agree with that causing
physical harm so like
if you harass someone nah like
harassment's a crime harassment isn't
like the way the left describes it on
twitter where someone calls it mean
words it's literally like you know
can beats him putting a bag of dog crap
on someone's porch every day for like
three years straight talking
intimidating
well that's just how you win a woman's
heart
pollution pollution is like you could
argue if that's causing harm to someone
or not
i guess i guess but it says physical
harm that's the issue
oh yeah like poisoning like taking a
poop in the river
you're not directly physically harming a
human but if they end up drinking that
water
in a couple days i need backup what's
going on we gotta code three he's
pooping in the river
don't you move he'll never stop me it's
my constitutional right
to in his river
all right i'll fight you naked says blm
wants police to let minorities kill each
other well okay
i mean look i'm not a fan of people
shooting each other or anything like
that or fighting each other but you've
really got to consider this one point
when the woman shot the other woman in
new york there's no national outcry
there's no protests i am not bringing it
up to say why aren't they doing it i'm
literally saying i get it
they don't care okay
when the cops show up and intervene they
get mad okay i get it
you don't want the cops you want to be
able to have these things happen in your
community
count me out do your thing you run your
community away you want to yeah
only certain black lives matter whoa
whoa whoa neversummer160 says
sheamus where the heck is the tim versus
shapiro video you promised us on
election night oh
did i promise that look at me making all
these promises writing all these checks
i can't cash
you should run for office i should
honestly i do a great job maybe we will
do tim versus what was it though
find me the clip find me the clip and
tweet it out i bet it what if i was just
like
vehemently insisting that the clip
doesn't exist and then people tweeted at
me and i'm like
this is it i'm over i have no
credibility wasn't the joke that we both
talk faster and faster until like
something
explodes or something happens like
something like that yeah yeah yeah
singularity event matter and anti-matter
second big bang both talk faster and
faster
all right we got a super chat here from
why is youtube mayor bear media
hypocrisy 13 year old girl in ohio
stabbed and killed
another 13 year old girl two days ago
have you heard anything about it
of course not no cop involved and not
narrative material
sure or i can just say these communities
want this
i don't want it in my community but i
don't live in their community
if they don't care about it am i
supposed to defend them nah
so i'm not going to bring it up but then
so but then this is
what the concern becomes if we start
allowing
parts of the first world to become
uncivilized in this manner and dangerous
doesn't it only spread i just i think
that
if we have that kind of community you
know where this kind of stuff happens is
happening then people will have to keep
and bear arms and be responsible for
themselves
i'll put it this way i remember a couple
years ago there this is probably
2016 there was the uh terror attack in
france and i was out to dinner with some
friends and i got a notification about
it on my phone
and this girl who i just met says the
only reason you care i just said a
little prayer about it and she said the
only reason you care is because it's in
france
it's it was in the developed world if
this happened in a third world country
she basically gave me the joker speech
like it's all part of the plan
and i was like well here's the thing
that actually i think it's horrible when
people get killed in any part of the
world
but the world is generally a dangerous
place but when a first world country
becomes less dangerous the entire world
becomes less dangerous because what we
have right now with the level of social
stability we're experiencing is an
absolute miracle
and when that starts to erode the
likelihood of us getting it back is very
very low and it makes the world as a
whole less dangerous because now there's
nowhere you can go which is safe and so
that's my fear about just allowing these
cities to fall to left-wing mobs
leftist activists and those who want to
abolish the police like antifa and blm
is we don't get it back and now the
world is significantly less safe overall
yeah all right we got noah says yo tim
when when will y'all have colleen noir
on he just did a podcast with rogan last
week it was great
uh whenever he wants to come on he
better stop by here next
well i'll tell you look high-profile
people who do their own shows
they're harder to book because they do
their own show they don't need to come
out here and talk to me about it right
so you know respect if uh if you made it
out here i'd be stoked and it would be
really awesome to film a vlog with him
and like go to the range
that would be amazing bring out the uh
the barrett
have him have a go at it that's right
all right christopher mellante says how
about a chicken city skyline shirt with
little chickens running around on it
yes well uh we we are doing some
preliminary work on chicken city
we want to bring we need to get a local
farmer to come and like help us
like make sure everything's set up
perfectly and uh they're doing pretty
well
someone advised us to get the nipple
waterer for the chickens
amazing they instantly just understood
how to drink from it it was beautiful
i just walked over and i like i i just
flicked it and the water came out they
started packing the thing and then the
water comes out
so we're gonna we need to get little
addresses for the houses yes
set the cameras up and then we're going
to have a 24 7 live chicken city
i just watch a video of chickens walking
around doing whatever i'm so excited
like randomly you could sell that to
true tv tim 100
yeah do it your next business venture
yeah
eric mancilla says cops should only show
up after the fact
like tim's rural sheriff let the
constitution shine no victim
less crimes americans should be
responsible for themselves period
absolutely imagine it this way someone
tries to break into my house
i protect myself afterwards i call the
police to come
take a statement gather evidence and
then you know
you're right to defend your property
clean up the mess
all right joseph allen says long time
watcher first time buyer girlfriend
would kill me since we have a baby girl
in the way haha
tim i'm in pittsburgh not far from you
what are you looking for uh
looking for as of employment
oh right now we're looking for a a
writer and
editor producer somebody who wants to
write about
paranormal mystery ufo sasquatch kind of
stuff
but definitely more from a like a
non-fiction
realistic perspective so like what could
the stories really be
what are our views so a very kind of
milk toast take on a lot of these
paranormal things but like legit
research
and we don't do it we want to do a
podcast from that we're actively looking
for someone who's going to write stories
and then use that for the show
because we want to launch that show
that's the we're also looking for a news
editor and writer
it's very difficult because got to know
how to write and edit articles and
understand basic rules of like real
journalism ethics
and uh i think for now we might actually
be looking for a couple of interns
to uh for like an hourly wage but we
probably would probably give everyone
some kind of
like decent pay because i'm kind of a
hippie and you know very nice seems like
i'm also
hiring someone to get jameis out of my
house like if he can get him yeah
frisky business says what's the deal
with the empty kami cola bottle tim
hope you shared it with the rest of the
cast that's hilarious
i i thought it was hilarious to have the
sickle in the hammer but this is called
lemonade
yes and uh it's hilarious and it's it's
just soda
and uh i was thirsty so i was like i'll
grab one of these i bought a bunch
because they're funny
yeah it's funny it's lenin aid i get it
and then under the bottle cap it says we
can write whatever we want here free
from censorship or something
i thought it was hilarious but there's
actually a thing in the bottle it says
cancel
common censorship defund the thought
police oh
i like that i love it i think they're
making fun of life get behind that there
you go good
they should all right wandering mage
says
when do we get the illinois boys t-shirt
tim i'd buy two
oh yeah a little cartoon of you me and
jack murphy just looking super cool
i miss dude i miss jack bring him back
right now illinois
next week we got way too many super
chats jack
yeah too many oh no too many super chats
trevor bullock says trevor hey tim
i am the original a-hole trevor i knew
it from michael malus twitter posts
we need a dylan avery jason burma's
luckowski loose change anniversary show
20 years never forget booyah oh luke's
gone
oh trevor luke's gone everybody tweeted
it over trevor he left
he have luke's static back he's got he's
not coming back
luke luke he's he's he's got a dog
all right adrian m says federal leo in
the process of leaving my six figure
salary i'm a former apache pilot and
combat veteran
decided to continue serving working for
the feds
after witnessing cops violating people's
rights and writing i'm out
cheers wow it's impressive yeah
it's a sacrifice sean easton says look
at little tim
look at little tim tim trying to write a
viral song he looks a little lost guess
i'll help him along what you got tim tim
tim on my door never mind that t i've
come to help you
won't regret it what is that i have no
idea
i'm way lost did you get that sheamus i
don't think so no i missed all that
but if they said it louder maybe you
need some music behind it if was it in
all caps
specialty i don't know blake salem says
the demoralization of police via media
propaganda is just one step in
federalizing the police force
you are too zoomed in on low brow social
justice agent prop and missed the big
picture
the great reset no i get it yeah yeah
they
they there are a lot of people who want
to have a
uh well the great reset i guess it's
easier we've talked about that
yeah multiple times and so that means
there's got to be a kind of
homogenization of culture
you know we can't have different areas
doing different things so
i wonder because we're it's actually
getting worse if people leave cities and
move to rural areas
it's actually the conservatives are
leaving and the democrats are
the liberals are staying so things are
becoming more red more blue it's
actually not homogenizing i think it's
splitting it up
yeah all right darren welch says hey tim
absolutely love the show
i'm going to give 100 super chat that i
want you to donate to kyle rittenhouse
and show everyone proof that you did so
show us how to have a spine and not be
afraid
please don't go on about why you won't
donate to the cause
thanks well i will tell you this uh
i would never i can't i can't predict
super chats on things like that
absolutely not if you super chat you
super chat i will tell you i will donate
to the cal right now defense fund
because
i think he deserves it and i have no
problem saying that roberto lara says
kinda odd my state gets the attention
for a riot bill and florida's
in blm's eyes are now let's pick on the
panhandle state like really guys
yeah they didn't they didn't come out in
in florida for this huh
yeah i was i did a segment where i was
really angry about this cop who got uh
fired for donating kyle rittenhouse
i think i think kyle rittenhouse uh
we've had four different witnesses on
this show
i think it's clear he he was defending
himself
they keep pushing lies about him saying
he crossed state lines with a gun he
didn't do that yep
i i just think if we can't protect our
own communities you know he's definitely
example of someone who did and the media
is lying to you about him
music dc guy says the right can't go out
and support the police and their
policies in their communities because
the left will just come out and cause
trouble
and the police will go after the people
from the right like we have seen before
that's why i'm not really i don't care
that much about the cops getting
defunded or abolished because
i watched them abuse small business
owners
and i watched a year of conservatives
getting outraged and angry the cops were
were yelling at them when they were
defending the cops
so there you go the cops will come out
and be like we support police and the
cops like they did in oregon
will start hitting the conservatives and
defending antifa so
why should i care i don't live there
anymore sheriff's departments and small
town
departments like tend to be all right
i'm talking about the big cities
like new york they have no problem
showing up to a bar and be like we're
going to arrest you for serving someone
beer
why does that guy get support i don't
think so
all right sam b says when your opponent
throws a punch at you you use the force
of their attack against them
pull the punch don't try to block it it
works with ideologies too
they want something crazy give it to
them i mean sure but i'm also just
saying
if someone in an area votes for
something why should i intervene and be
like i don't live here but you should do
what i want
nah whatever do what you want
all right frank carr says d-e-a-d-e-a
agents
kill same demographics as local but the
dea and fbi
never end up in the news only local cops
now a federal audit of minneapolis cops
clearly a campaign to federalize law
enforcement
it'll be interesting uh i mean
actually i wonder if that would be a
good thing how would the federal
government handle uh
second amendment drones dude drone
weapons what
they're not gonna drone people who own
guns i'm talking about whether or not
they're going to ban or confiscate
now dc has got really strict gun laws so
maybe not a good thing people are like
i'm not coming out i'm keeping my
weapons you come and get me
they'll drop a bomb on the house to get
rid of them they're allowed
and kill all the people around yeah dude
it's crazy it's psychotic what
a militarized authoritarianism a
government will do it's
not gonna go that way on that one i'm
with you on that one all right lua coder
says hey tim i'd really recommend you
reach out to
louis rossman oh he runs a small macbook
repair business in new york and
advocates
for a mostly unheard of issue of our
time right to repair
i'd really like for you to have him on
love you guys i have heard this name
cool i'll see if i can reach out
all right let's see i'm talking worst
worst case scenario with this drone
yeah no it's not like they're just going
to be droning everybody and i don't even
know if it'll necessarily be drones but
i completely agree with you that they
have no problem
i mean in the past they've killed
innocent people they do it in
afghanistan yeah
they do it once that's a precedent they
burn those people alive
they didn't need drones and waco they
made it happen all right amanda
dilts i think says hey oklahoman here
we have some good things like twister
but some sad things like black wall
street and the okc bombing
the anniversary was just last monday
keep it the good work on the other hand
all the respect to lids that keeps the
show flowing thank you
i enjoyed oklahoma when we drove through
there some nice bird song
rail jb says i wish you guys had a call
in line those are
really hard to do if not impossible to
do live videos you have a friend who's
trying to do it it's challenging
on youtube definitely there's so many
things youtube will just instantly shut
you down for you she really wants to
yeah that's a good point pirate queen
says in kansas they're opening a
bsl4 lab that would study hoof
foot and mouth if another wuhan accident
you know happened it would wipe out cows
and hogs well i don't know if there was
an accident wuhan
but you're saying if there was an
accident at the bio was it what is bsl
biosecurity yeah level four yeah
all right clef the misfit says hey
sheamus can we get your best stephen
crowder impression
don't forget to intermittently switch
the speed of your talking
for no reason all right so this is this
is really bad i admit this is not a good
impression but if you want to if you
want to see like
how the sausage gets made you know if
you kind of want to see where i'm at at
this point
so crowding like he starts kind of like
slow and then it gets like really
fascinating
it gets like really really high um i
can't i can't really do full yeah
crowder is difficult because his voice
is more normal but then he starts he
starts like
look i don't like sojournalism it's all
right you want to feed people what
you're eating your dog and i'm like
and it's like so he starts very slow and
then he gets like he gets really high
pitched and really fast that's pretty
much all i got so far
you're right and part so part of the
thing is i i have been trying to figure
the impression of him out um
because whenever i don't have like a
good impression of anyone i just end up
being unintentionally mean
like with the day like with with the
dave rubin one i just i noticed he said
agree funny so i would just go i
agree and everyone's like dude you like
scorched him i was like i just didn't
have a good impression of gabriel but
like that's why i did that
um i'm sorry but he was very cool about
it but that said yeah that's i i want to
really get the crowder impression
figured out
the best was the video where you said if
right-wingers were left-wingers or
whatever oh my god and the finale
spoiled the finale no you guys have to
watch it tim said it's the best you
heard it here
the finale is dave rubin and it's just
the perfect callback joke
absolutely perfect and speaking of which
we
are just over 500 subs away from
reaching
ladies 100 gentlemen let's smash that
like button i mean that subscribe button
i knew i was gonna have a gaffe on
tonight's show oh come on joe
brian triplett says sure shouldn't shoot
them in the leg
several femoral artery and they have
seven seconds to live good plan yeah
exactly that's right
if you hit the leg cam says let's get
freedom tunes to a million subscribers
right now tonight we get a million
subscribers
just look i was able to get tim two
million subscribers all right i can get
freedom too
yeah ghost f says i think it's foolish
for conservatives to abandon cities
a lot of money power and influence comes
from cities true in every civilization
if only one faction rules rome they rule
the whole empire
but one faction does rule rome right now
and conservatives are just sitting there
and taking it if they were a political
force that was actually affecting
substantial change i would agree but
they're pretty much
useless as a voting group in large
cities yep
twitch grip says people want police to
use non-lethal force but want to abolish
them so what force are people going to
use
if they police themselves tasers and
rainbows that's what i'm saying you
abolish the police and then
what do we do get social workers oh i
guess people can buy a rubber buckshot
or something
everyone will walk around we'll have
social workers we'll have social workers
who just fire guns into the air
yeah do we just let out to just let out
two blasts
i'm sorry oh our safety experts i love
them
jinx snead says you haven't caught on
yet they want to replace the police with
a political uh police force
we're in a war and haven't realized it
yet that's why we will lose
look into the spanish civil war i did i
that's why i've been saying
you know the problem is conservatives
refuse to fight yeah
there you go people might i think milo
posted something on uh on gab i think it
was where said there was no conservative
movement it's just a fundraising machine
oh man it's brutal he's not wrong he's
not entirely wrong
oh this is cool american capitalist says
alaska is constitutional carry too
we probably have more guns per capita
than anywhere else but more dying plane
crashes
we've had two mass shootings one in the
80s and a domestic violence armed
society polite society
but does does alaska have fiber optic or
gigabit internet or both whatever
also i think like plane rides are more i
know someone who went to alaska recently
and there are a lot of locations you can
really only access by plane because they
don't
yeah you can't yeah yeah exactly so
that's probably why more people die in
plane crashes but agreed
i can't imagine that the gun deaths are
a substantial problem in alaska
grim beckons says people seem to forget
the police aren't there for you
they're the enforcement and protection
arm of the state at the end of the day
they aren't on your side and your
opinion doesn't matter
and that's true yeah that's why even
there was a famous supreme court justice
who said don't talk to cops
yeah 100 like really famous like retired
cops who like spoken up and said don't
talk to cops yeah no i
we talked about this when we had the
illinois boys all together in the good
old days back when we were all happy and
two weeks ago um
i was talking about this like my uncles
are all cops and my parents respect the
police
but they told me as a kid never talk to
the cops ever
josh nelson says hey ian have you
watched the new trailer for age of
empires 4 yet looks pretty rad dude
no i have not gotta check it out
no one out dominic says no one
outpolices the hut
yes that's right
benzie bach says please have dave smith
on he might have some disagreements but
only because he does not bulge from
values
dave smith yeah dave smith oh yeah we
had him
yeah he's right he's hilarious yeah
fred f says tim you're 100 correct about
the police stop going where you're not
wanted
that's what i'm saying like the people
are like officer please don't come here
and like i'm gonna go anyway it's like
well maybe you shouldn't
maybe you should just be like nah you're
good that's it
the late the the the the shooting that
with this girl the six year old girl
apparently
she's the one who called the police oh
wow she got she called the police the
cop shows up she got an ipod to stab
somebody so the cop shoots her and now
everyone's like what have you done it's
like
maybe you shouldn't have showed up well
i don't get it they don't want you there
why would you go
i mean he did he did save a life he
absolutely did yeah
would have been one of the other took a
life yeah saved a life though i mean he
shot the stabber and stuff and what are
they mad about
yeah they're mad about that no i
completely agree they're not like that's
another girl who killed the other girl
look he i i agree that it's totally
thankless but
i think it's good that he saved a life
absolutely
yeah and she was very grateful but i
think at a certain point
you know i think about people having the
responsibility and rights of their own
communities and if they want to be
like she apparently was getting jumped
and was fighting with people with a
knife
so i don't know the full story but fair
if fair that's fair if people are
arguing that they should have the right
to to hash out their own problems in
their own communities
oh boy yeah i don't know man i don't
it doesn't feel right to me for me to be
like nah i'm gonna bring a guy with guns
who doesn't live there to go into your
neighborhood and tell you what to do
she did call him didn't you say that
that's what they're gonna report that
she was the one who actually called the
cops
and she ended up being shot thomas bale
says
i'm waiting for antipa to enter my
neighborhood pretty sure from my super
high two and a half story bedroom window
no i'm not gonna read the rest of that
but people are basically saying they
better not come to my neighborhood
they're prepared that's right people are
prepared
matt voelker says ryan long did a
blogger trump withdrawal video that was
spot-on
very funny but he didn't dig through the
carpet for
uh parmesan
oh here we go justin jar jar says james
o'keefe is batman
oh ooh i mean
if there's one person who's actually
fighting as hard as they possibly can
it's james okay yeah i could see it
not only doing the journalism work but
actually suing and going after the
corrupt
amazing all right let's see where we are
at with some super chats best auntie
ever says i went down a rabbit hole
today watching freedom tunes
so freaking funny so many tears from
laughing so hard great work
thank you thank you sub we are i think
about twenty away from six hundred
thousand
that's it you're already you can't see
it yet oh we yeah less than ten
we're almost there we're almost there do
it more milestones on air
all right angsta says we had no batman
in this timeline we just had dent
trump and joker media oh no if only we
had a batman to protect trump from the
media
a man can dream wait oh i see
it was steve bannon band man protecting
him from the media
yeah but but uh den became the bad guy
in the end and then yeah
the batman had to take the fall for him
i guess
we'd have somebody who would be the
scapegoat for the media so that trump
would get reelected
yeah yeah i don't know who that would be
joe by the way a hunter
now uh ladies and gentlemen boys and
girls
yes we have reached 600
000 subscribers thank you so much what
an unbelievable blessing
god bless all of you thanks for having
me on the show tim and i i just don't
want to
thank my audience and and thank the
people who have been contributing and
helping the the animators who helped me
with this stuff thank you all so much
couldn't have done it without you
and god and saint joseph of course
naturally dress
noodle soup says consider watching the
red pill documentary
also rest in peace mark angelici
angelucci
truly uh tully bloom says tim i have a
story that i need to tell i'm betting
everything on black i have pictures and
testimony that i'm willing to give
i don't care where i go from there but
it's what i must do
okay let's see
channern says at this point i want to
defund the police i am tired of them
arresting law-abiding citizens defending
themselves we will take out the trash
look i'm saying we should have a
responsibility to protect ourselves
if they don't want the cops protect
ourselves
az says cnn is the joker brian stelter
it's all part of the plan i want you to
not get elected but you're just so
fun you're just too much fun joker dude
that's hilarious you have nothing to
threaten me with
i can see it they need him they really
did and now he's gone and they are
begging for him to run in 2024.
yeah i think we tim we might have talked
about this last time it's like a bit but
uh or months and months ago but wouldn't
it be hilarious if like cnn just starts
to fail because trump is gone and
there's nothing to talk about
so no no so he buys cnn when their stock
value is really low and they just become
the pro-trump network
yes that'd be hilarious i would like
that garhent says sheamus please do a
spoof
romance novel cover of trump as flabio
shirtless
lion's mane glowing orange holding a
swooning tim saying he wished he could
quit him
oh my god i don't i don't know tim
wouldn't
she wouldn't approve i don't consent no
one consents here
all right 20 something drifter says tim
and crew i recommend reading
americans to secessia and divided we
fall american secession and divided we
fall
both books examine how the u.s could
break up and scenarios for how the
country could fracture
interesting pete rock a3 says
i believe the police should be more
afraid of treating citizens like
prisoners
the cop that pepper sprayed that vet
literally said you're about to ride the
lightning
what oh man police default in most
situations are set
are our set butthole look man the moment
conservatives started like protesting
the cops just went
ape against the conservatives yeah and
the conservatives were more than happy
to sit back and like go police
then the police got attacked then the
right came out and protested and then
the cops turned on the right and
that's a rude wake-up call i guess
ryan swagger says sheamus please do a
biden handing out commons and
com condoms in the ghetto tune i think
y'all could add some real magic to that
one i just so tim and cass i love you
yeah i just i can't believe he said and
also like i think some people thought in
the chat that i was joking earlier like
he actually said that also like a
catholic politician should not be doing
that like that is
explicitly contradicted by catholic
teaching but he's he's devout you know i
mean that's
also just like a really weird thing a
really weird thing to do yeah also
yes 100 and then to like brag about it
wow cody wilson says tim big fan here
i'm a police officer but after the
events of this past year i will be
turning in my badge no longer see the
point anymore
mad respect i mean it um i think it's a
combination of
depends on where you are for sure but
standing up for your dignity
for for your rights and your respect and
also knowing when the cities don't want
you and they won't stand up for you
yeah one of my best buds uh i've
mentioned it before he's
a combat veteran who was a police
officer for a while i remember him
telling me years ago
uh or he told me recently that he did
this years ago he left the police force
because he's like i just i just don't
want to be a part of this and he's not
he's not exactly a lefty i think it's
just happening where a lot of people are
becoming disaffected because
they see how the machine operates and
they don't like it yeah
hunter kotz says the funniest thing
about the lemonade bottle is the fact
that it's empty
quite telling well it's empty because i
drank it he did drink it
i'm pretty sure they're not communists
that's really funny though yeah
what is it okay let's uh
pj littlefoot says trump just realized a
statement
just released well it says realized but
released a statement involving lebron
james
finally sub to your channel sheamus
thank you so much
thank you so much you were you were part
you subbed on a historic day
this is a good day for freedom tunes
fans everywhere heck yeah
all right smoke says hey tim cast crew i
am a scooter writer i know a few
interesting people from the scooter and
glassblowing community
i took a short video pitching why i
would be an asset to the team
as an intern where can i send it love
y'all pitches
at timcast.com that sounds like a pitch
yes a pitch
and uh if you got some sweet scooter
moves then we could film some vlogs with
you
it's a mini ramp and the uh the ledges
and stuff it'd be great fun
i want to see a cool scooter move yeah i
want to see some back flips
some flares julie simone says not sure
we'll ever find a middle ground with
black lives matter and policing issues
you can't have a rational conversation
with people who are irrational and
emotional
it's gone too far people will flee
cities sorry charlie
i'm with sheamus safety first mm-hmm
yeah and also
it's not as if we have common ground
with blm per se because the issue
the reasons for which we are
disillusioned with the police are very
different very different from theirs
there's there's some overlap i mean
no one wants citizens to be treated
poorly or hurt by the police on the
basis of their skin color but so often
these stories are
so often these stories are like taken
out of context and you have people like
michael brown who are killed when they
were clearly attacking the police
officer and martyrs are made of them so
no we're not affiliating ourselves with
that movement at all but there are there
are reasons to be concerned about
policing in this country 100 you don't
have to support that marxist movement to
recognize that
yep and thank you thank you for having
me back by the way to the last super
chatter 100
leave the cities unless you're a lib
then prove how well they work by staying
there and not voting where i live
i like this argument i'm on board with
this
so i will just shout uh shout out to a
lot of people we had a couple super
chats
you know they'll superchat again being
like hey you missed my super chat can
you read it
um it's challenging you know yeah i i we
try
we have so many super chats that come in
so i just try and read as many as
possible
i try to read thank you everyone not
based on necessarily the amount but
just what i can and it moves so quick
you know that's like by the time i see
your message saying can you read my
other thing it's like i don't even know
what that is bro i'm sorry
yeah lapco 92 says i live in okc and had
no idea anything happened yesterday
our black lives matter is a bit more
tame than elsewhere but our citizenry is
well armed
very good could be that the local media
isn't that's why they're more tame
that's probably true man why they're
more yeah jim rogers says trump is in
modern day napoleon
given the power to control the country
but then exiled when he pushed too hard
interesting jeffrey grunts says tim
don't forget
in the first mad max film mad max was a
law enforcement officer
he quit before the before the downfall
of humanity
very interesting i haven't seen that i
haven't seen mad max
my friends thank you so much for hanging
out smash that like button
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
already and hit the notification bell
share the show if you really like it if
you're listening on itunes or spotify
share with your friends it really really
does help and leave us a good review
leave us five stars
you can follow me on social media at tim
cast across the board
you can check out the social media for
this show go on facebook
facebook.comcast irl click that like
button and on instagram
irl you'll see clips from the show and
funny bits it's good fun and you can
help share those socials if you want to
help promote the show
my other youtube channels are
youtube.com slash timcast and
youtube.comcastnews
and we have the vlog up if you haven't
seen it already it's called cast castle
you can search for it
we haven't really done a lot of work
it's probably hard to find but somehow
people are finding it's got a couple
hundred thousand views which is epic
and we're going to be having a new
episode coming up this sunday and
filming another episode
and then we're going to be slowly moving
into daily vlogs an entirely new show
it's gonna be a lot of fun so thanks so
much for hanging out sheamus i think you
have a youtube channel
i do so we actually don't need any more
subscribers so don't even bother right
we're done i'm kidding everyone i'm
kidding we're we're at six hundred
thousand no yes thank you so much for
getting me to six hundred thousand and
this is not just
my accomplishment i mean genuinely i to
get out a cartoon every week or this
week three cartoons a week has required
a lot of help from some really talented
animators
so i want to thank them and i want to
thank all of you who support the show
who subscribe and the people who donate
at patreon.com
freedomtunes to help us raise the funds
to get these cartoons done so god bless
all of you thank you
thanks st joseph um and i i massively
appreciate the opportunity to be here
tim
any time brother uh yeah you guys can
also follow me in crossland and ian
crosson.net
um don't give up faith guys uh i know
things are a little at least i'm a
little depressed about this situation i
feel like staring into the problem
for a long time can drive you insane so
there are ways to change the system
without focusing on the problem
you just gotta go under it look at the
roots
i think i think i'd agree with you know
go home love your family be a good
person take care of those around you
it doesn't always have to be focused on
the system specifically could just be
living virtuously
that's a good point yeah and i saw a
super chat earlier this evening that i
wanted to mention since
ian just talked somebody was talking
about how they went to
iancrasscrossland.net and they listened
to some of his music and it quote
slaps and i'm not entirely sure what
that means but i believe
it's a good thing so someone was really
enjoying your music ian yeah you can
search for me on
uh on amazon music and all that if you
want to hear songs by
ian crossland is there another ian
crossland i doubt it okay i mean there
are but
not musicians that i know only one of
you but i am sarah patchell it's on
twitter if you would like to join me in
my quest to beat sourpatch kids
in follower count i know i'm very
excited and here's tim
we will have an exclusive members only
segment coming up at timcast.com it's
about an hour or so so make sure you go
to timcast.com
you can click the members area pick any
one of these you know little
segments or click the members only in
the top right and then you can sign up
at whatever tier you'd like we're
starting to plan also live
events so it means fridays we're
planning on having jam sessions with
music
a lot of work has to get done we've got
to set up the the studio outside which
means we've got to hire a bunch of
people
maybe by next year everything will be
like this massive
media empire for now we're slowly just
building things up and we're getting
there we're getting there so uh thanks
for being members and we'll see you all
in the exclusive members only segment
at teamcast.com bye guys
you